so Vladimir Putin's all like yo you know
that last nuclear treaty that y'all got
gone over and uh I don't know if it
really matters to be honest it was about
non-proliferation it was the new Stark
treaty and it was about inspections
between countries but at this point it's
laughable that the treaty would even be
considered in existence so we can say
Vladimir Putin he's saying no more to
this treaty but come on the moment the
U.S basically went to war with Russia
and we did right saying we but where's
the United States that treaty didn't
exist Russia's not going to let U.S or
NATO or U.N inspectors into its country
when we're actively supplying Military
Intelligence weapons and Personnel on
the ground in Ukraine in their country's
border dispute so that being said
there's a journalist out of Russia who
says the U.S has already he declared war
on Russia I don't know how many pundits
in Russia have said they are going to
use nuclear weapons so I don't know one
more grain of sand in the Heat and you
know it is it is tough every day to come
in and you read the news and it's
something I don't know it's increasingly
inane to me to see stories of like some
woke college leftists and I'm like it's
been 10 years of seeing these people
scream on the internet I know I know for
a lot of people it's funny but at the
same time I'm kind of like man I'm
feeling my priorities shift towards are
we going to be self-sustainable because
it doesn't seem like this train is
stopping Joe Biden does a surprise
secret trip to Ukraine to give him half
a billion dollars ignores the people of
East Palestine Vladimir Putin then comes
out gives him his his state of the
nation address or whatever in Russia and
says this treaty is done pundits in
Russia are calling for and have been for
months now the use of nuclear weapons
and either just shut up and stop okay
Putin and Biden or or get or get on with
it it's the waiting I can't stand right
are we going to war come on I'm gonna
see here we're how many episodes of ir
what are we gonna do talking about how
they're they're wagging their their
their Sabers at each other both
figuratively and literally anyway we'll
talk about that plus we got a bunch of
other stories National divorce is
currently trending because Marjorie
Taylor Greener that I called for now
everyone's opining on whether or not
they actually want one what's
interesting about this story is that as
much as we talk about the fear or the
prospects of Civil War all of a sudden
now there's a big cultural debate on
Civil War I mean okay there have been a
few people who have called for in the
past no one really opined much on it now
all of a sudden with Marjory Taylor
green I suppose a federal level
politician calling for one now we're
seeing pundits be like whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay this is getting a little
serious but let's talk about it plus
other stuff you know we got uh Alec
Baldwin has charges degraded
unsurprising yeah he's gonna get a slap
on the wrist but let's we'll get into
all that before we do head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
that join us button I got news I'm gonna
I'm just gonna announce it right now and
hopefully it works out but uh we have a
new show
that uh is is going to be on Fridays
probably going up at 1 p.m it's called
we're calling it I guess uh the culture
war with Tim pool and uh it's gonna be
on youtube.com timcast the idea for this
is I mentioned it the other day so we'll
have it up on the website as well we'll
probably have a members only uncensored
segment much the same as Tim cast IRL or
something of that effect and the general
idea is there are a lot of guests that
we could have on this show there are a
lot of high profile people begging us to
come on but the issue is always hey guys
we're we're a topical news and cultural
commentary show that takes the top news
of the day and then is a conversation
around them so if you're a scientist a
doctor a zoologist or uh some some
internet influencer or personality
it doesn't necessarily work I mean we've
had some guests many of you may even
notice are like hey they're not really
adding a lot to the conversation and
those people will say things like Tim
let the guests speak and I'm like this
is the challenge with a guest that is a
specialist so we try to have them on
Fridays but even that's still a little
difficult so we decided you know what
let's just do a new show on youtube.com
timcast which will be a two on two hour
straight cultural conversation not news
topics segmented by you know 10 to 15
minutes literally just more like Club
random or Joe Rogan or whatever we're
gonna sit down we're gonna hang out
we're gonna have coffee film Friday
morning uploaded Friday afternoon and
this Friday we have Ali London so if
you're not familiar with Ali London he
is an influencer who decided uh he was
trans Korean and then transgender Korean
and now is uh detransitioned so this is
going to be a really interesting
conversation I'm actually really excited
we had Ali hit us up saying that he
wanted to come on timcast IRL and uh or
or just come and talk and I just said
you know like the issue is if we're
talking about World War III or something
it doesn't make sense to have like a
cultural influencer on the show but a
new show does make sense so it'll be
once a week it'll be its own podcast
it'll be on iTunes Spotify Etc it'll be
at youtube.com timcast plus we're gonna
devise some kind of members only version
uh additional bonus content for
timcast.com
and uh I'm a crazy person who just keeps
working and and doing more and more and
more despite the fact I should probably
be doing less and hiring more people to
do other things but I appreciate all of
the support of all of you who helped
make all this possible and um you know
hopefully this this new show works out
and takes off I think we'll be able to
hit on a lot of uh new subject matter we
normally don't get to because typically
what I do is either direct article
commentary on news or we bring in a
guest and then talk about top news we we
don't get an opportunity as often to
talk about you know
crazier ideas and things that are on the
periphery of of modern culture stuff so
so that's thanks to you for being
members we're able to do things like
this experiment try it out I'm really
excited and then we have some big
musicians and some celebrities who are
who are asking us to come on as well so
I think the show might kick off with
some really big guests should be really
interesting joining us today are smash
the like button subscribe to the Channel
all that good stuff joining us today to
talk about this and a whole lot more is
Bill Atman hey welcome back to me yeah
good to see you Tim cast yeah my name is
Bill I'm the founder CEO at
mindsminds.com m i n d s.com not
the I need to getminds.com so that
people don't think that we're a coal
mine operation Tim has brought that up
many times before but yeah we're a free
speech social network
focused on actual first amendment
content policy
um I think Twitter is slowly getting
there but they are not there and they're
still doing
these interstitial content policies all
over the world and and following content
guidelines of places like the EU so we
got to be careful of that and hold Elon
to account we love you Elon but you
gotta open source all the code and Go
full free speech cool I'm Hannah Claire
brimlow I'm a writer for timcast.com you
should follow at timcast news on Twitter
and Instagram Hi Ian cross and I
actually co-founded mines with Bill in
like 2011 or something like that right
it was like the when it was still in
pre-alpha early determination rounds and
we were kind of figuring out what the
hell is going to happen you know when we
talk about the first amendment on the
internet I think a lot of it is actually
translating to ability to view and
utilize code that's your First Amendment
right on the internet because like a
network controller should I think should
always have the right to ban whoever
they want if they are running a network
but that doesn't mean that they should
be the only one that has access to that
kind of network so that's an idea uh
let's go deeper on it on the show yeah
because I want to introduce Serge duprea
hey what's up surge.com
um I'm excited for this because you're
the founder of the website Ian always
talks about yeah and uh good and the
Supreme Court heard arguments on Section
230 today so yeah that's apply come up
all right let's jump into the news man
we got the story from the hill Russia
suspends only remaining nuclear treaty
with U.S Russian President Vladimir
Putin declared Tuesday that Moscow was
suspending its participation in the new
start treaty the last remaining nuclear
arms control pact with the United States
sharply upping the anti-amid tensions
with Washington over the fighting in
Ukraine okay I just guys it's it's so
difficult I can't look if you're gonna
nuke just do it okay it's the waiting I
can't stand we've been sitting here for
a year with these guys going like oh
I'll nuke you I'm gonna you don't do
don't you do it and then we keep doing
these shows where they're like oh boy oh
man they're threatening us and then
nothing happens yeah so I'm kidding I'm
okay with the waiting I'm okay yeah
it's not that I want anyone to be bomb
but I'm running out of ways to say amid
Rising tensions like as things continue
like I can't say it the same way a
hundred times and to that extent like I
like assumed the American public is also
exhausted it's been over a year at this
point we've hit the year mark
when are we going to see the other boot
drop like how long do we just stay in
the perpetual and they tricked us
they've got us being here being like
come on already yeah what are you doing
yeah you're a pro war now dude yeah
right no uh but the scary thing is that
we're desensitized to it this news comes
out and people just shrug at it like oh
because
it's it's what we were talking about the
other day you know nobody nobody uh sits
there watching the grass grow and then
eventually just goes whoa whoa the grass
got too long no you ignore it and then
one day you walk outside you go oh grass
is getting long better mow it and that's
what's happening with this
it's incrementally getting worse but not
enough to where anybody actively is
freaking out or people are shutting down
government like with protests or
anything like that they're ignoring it
and as long as they keep Slow Rolling it
the way they do it will just escalate to
that point it's not going to be one day
the air right Sirens go off and nuke
drops on Kiev and we're like wow I can't
believe it's happened by the time an
actual ICBM hits a city we're going to
be like oh another one it's going to be
incremental the point where people are
just like well that's War I mean look at
what's going on in Ukraine right now
that's been going on for a year with
with you know the the Air Raids the
missile strikes the the misfires hitting
Poland there's been so much War the
crazy thing to me is
50 years from now they will write about
the ukraine-russia conflict probably the
nato-russia conflict because it's going
to escalate we're in it right now and it
seems like
non-existent far away it's it's been so
gradual that we are not shocked that
there is a land war in Eastern Europe at
this point we're bored with it that's
the scary thing well and we're not even
talking about the Middle East at all
so which is not like there's nothing
going on there
there's tons of stuff going on but I
think we just got this slow boil to the
point where everyone is completely used
to that father right I mean I remember
writing about you know the months
leading up before Russia invaded there's
troops on the border there's troops on
the border there's troops on the border
Russia says it's not a big deal Russia
says it's just a military exercise and
then like they talked to Biden and it
just went on and eventually you know it
felt like a big moment in time but then
we continued on we know there's conflict
we know there's there's mounting uh
geopolitical tension everywhere but to
what end right if if you are American if
you're an American going about your
day-to-day life like there isn't a major
change it's not like Russia has now also
invaded Pol like Poland it's they
they're staying where that where they
are and so therefore it doesn't feel
like an escalation when we learn when
you learn about War retrospectively
you're able to say you know if even
though things things happen over three
or four or five years you learn about
them in quick succession so it feels
faster I have two a friend out in L.A
who I'm not going to name his name
because it's what he said to me I feel
absolutely ridiculous we'll call him
bill for the sake of the argument he has
two kids they're like 10 and 7. and like
dude do you you want to send your kids
over there because if you really think
Ukraine is Ukraine get out Putin you're
willing to send him over there you want
to see his legs get blown off by a
mortar
what do you say I didn't ask I'm asking
you right now dude are you willing to
put your kids over there because that
that's the direction look come on man
you know this is the thing that's so
tiring these these these liberal types
who wave the flags of course they would
never send their own kids I don't think
you have a choice if you if you set this
ball in motion gravity takes over you
can't stop it listen these are people
who Gorge themselves on hojos and Ding
Dongs and then demand that you pay for
their health care and the worst part is
this is that's not even this guy this
guy's like legit but he's he's in it
he's in that liberal state of La like
willing to throw his children away
because of Joe Biden like Joe Biden told
him so I don't I don't get it man you
think that East Palestine Ohio is bad
imagine if that was intentionally done
to the city nine times a day to nine
different cities by by a foreign
government that you have no control to
stop
that's what that's the precipice and
imagine you have one time one time and
East Palestine happens to only 5 000
people
and the President says I will not go
there and then secretly travels to a
foreign country Halfway Around the World
to give half a billion dollars to we
could not get action on Flint we could
not get action on Newark and Pittsburgh
and it was the left being like yo fix
these things Joe Biden snaps his fingers
to hop on a plane and fly to Ukraine for
half a billion dollars for our country
nobody in most people can't even find on
the map I like Ukraine man I don't like
I don't like what Russia is doing I get
it there's conflict we talk all day and
night about Prisma the energy sector
Nordstrom all that stuff but it's just
really gut punching demoralization when
the president outright says I will not
visit East Palestine these people you
just got to understand about this train
train crash Benny Johnson do you guys
see this video he went out and gave 20
grand he found the 20 houses surrounding
the closest 20 houses surrounding the
disaster he gave me to him a thousand
bucks that's really great I do I'll I'll
do the hassanism of does it really have
to be some commentator to go and give
money to these poor people why can't Joe
Biden why can't the government do
anything to to help these people I pay
taxes I have no problem with the
government being like yeah portion of
those taxes are going to go to make sure
that the disaster is cleaned up cleaned
up because it's kind of like Hey we're
paying for something right no no no no
no no no no no not only will he not go
there he'll go and give your money away
to a foreign country for a war that we
don't know anything about or why it's
happening and they try and convince us
we got to stand with Ukraine for what
reason are we are we at war in Ukraine
for what reason I mean I know it's
energy conflict it's Nordstrom it's gas
prom it's the cutter turkey pipeline
it's uh it's NATO expansion it's U.S
Global Empire it's NATO expansion it's
western expansion for what reason do we
not provide even a tiny bit of relief to
the people of East Palestine yeah well
so Betty Johnson shout out twenty
thousand dollars that's and I I know
Benny would do more if he could he
probably was like what can we afford a
spare in this budget and so he breaks
down where the money comes from and so
that's it it's up to a a culture and
political commentator to try and give
money to some of these people can we can
we take that 500 million dollars to
Ukraine and even one percent of it to
the people who are starting this
disaster because here's what you gotta
understand about that they've lost
everything those houses are worth zero
dollars now no one is going to buy a
house contaminated with vinyl chloride
and you know whatever glycol garbage is
all over the place I think it's more
than just culture uh commentators the
Michael Reagan the head of the EPA was
supposed to go to a climate a climate
change tour in Africa with Idris Elba
and then on the 17th Trump announced
that he was going to go to East
Palestine on the 18th the EPA announced
that tour was canceled on the 19th uh
Reagan it's like oh I'll be in I'll be
in Palestine this come East Palestine
this coming week and then he announces
oh we're going to hold Norfolk Southern
accountable for what they've done we're
going to make them pay for it which I'm
not saying it that company shouldn't but
this is the same federal government that
said that the people of East Palestine
didn't qualify for FEMA relief right
they didn't they they weren't enough of
a disaster to get assistance but then
when we have an unrelenting especially
conservative leaning media that's like
no we want to talk about it we want you
to go there we want you to drink the
water then eventually the EPA is like
yeah we've got to hold that private
company accountable I'm not saying
that's the wrong step I'm just saying
why were you thinking about going to
Africa to talk about climate change when
we have our own disaster in our backyard
this is like I don't think that waiting
for someone to do it is gonna they're
gonna do it but there's a technology
where you can clean up oil spills with
magnets this is developed about a decade
ago CNN reports on it you type up
cleanup oil spill with magnet and it'll
come up and put iron iron into the water
and then the oil like coagulates around
the iron water there is oil there's lots
of stuff in it exactly but if it's a
start I mean it's it's a suggestion that
maybe we can do something to clean this
up
I mean Ian that's it's not that far from
your hometown so no it's like 70 miles
from my hometown oh yeah it's pretty
close
so maybe you need to go at some point
I'm sure you will maybe if you go home
and visit I thought I think you'd do a
visit dude I thought about going there
just to smell just to smell it to know
is this gonna kill people like Because
unless you go and then I was like I
don't want to be there I don't want to
hurt my lungs and I'm like what what
that is that's what Biden say did he
actually say I'm not going there or he's
just not say anything the bite it was
Kareem Jean-Pierre I'm pretty sure was
asked and he said he has no plans to
that's because he's too sickly to handle
the air no no there's just no plans I
don't know if it was Korean Jean-Pierre
but the administration answered that
they had no plans and then everyone got
really mad because Trump then announced
I will be going to visit it's remarkable
man Trump for all of the awful things
people have complained about actually
cares about this country and Joe Biden
is representing some kind of occupying
force that cares more about West Western
power expansion than the people who are
doing the hard work to make this place
exist
Donald Trump struck the perfect balance
in my opinion he cared about foreign
policy he was negotiating peace deals he
wanted NATO to pay their fair share he
wasn't ignoring foreign policy but he
also made sure that the support
structure the infrastructure of this
country its people were being taken care
of perfect of course not Joe Biden and
the Democrats completely reject and
ignore the support structure of this
country and what it represents the
people and then he decides to do a
surprise trip to smile I mean I'm just
it is is a degree of triggered that I am
to see Biden hugging zelenski and
smiling
and then watching Benny Johnson's video
where he's like here's the best I can do
a thousand dollars and I'm like half a
billion dollars to to Ukraine for what
reason
and then the worst thing is we've had
rail workers threatening to strike
complaining about the safety issues
warning something like this was going to
happen see we're seeing we see more
derailments all the time but this was a
massive disaster the media then lies
about it and says everything's fine the
AP if you think anything's wrong with
the air water you're a right-wing
conspiracy theorist you know you gotta
listen to these Railway workers man and
you got to look at these railroad uh the
rail tracks because they get Warped and
bent there's a video of it I mean they
are Beyond fathomably bent and warped
and the trains like bouncing I saw that
yeah it's not just like they get a
little messed up and oops it actually
gets blown off yeah we got to pull this
up when you see how start how bad these
rails can get and you realize that if we
don't when they say we need to reinvest
in our infrastructure this is what
they're talking about is we need to pull
these up and re-lay really new age
strong material look at this
is there sound on this thing
yeah there's sound let's let's
so for those that are just listening
we're showing you completely mangled and
bent tracks is this even the us though
ndnw Railway Mommy and Western
seems like us yeah
and the people were so I I I this video
was going viral people were sharing it
uh this is from March 31st 2017 but they
were look at this it's in Michigan it
says in Michigan Napoleon Defiance and
Western railroad is the ndw look at this
so the train has to slow down like
drastically even to get over wow look
it's on it's at an angle but hey 100
billion dollars in Ukraine well they
really need it well what's the structure
of those uh deals with Ukraine like is
like what are we owed after the fact
it's not just a straight donation or
like a Lend Lease yeah what oh right
right but there is black Rockets to come
in and divvy up the land that's what
they did the Americans in World War II
as they lent the British so much money
that they had them by the balls after
the war right and that's why America was
so powerful after the war let's say you
know so are we sure this is in the US
where'd it say Michigan well I see in
the chat someone saying mommy is in Ohio
so this is the Michigan Southern and
this is a story full video uh Story full
is owned by Fox News
so uh operates between Woodburn Indiana
and Napoleon Ohio compromises 58 miles
of track yeah so it's not too far to
expect that that's probably part of the
issue those are the conditions yeah and
they took they said it was mechanical
failure and that the axle that was
keeping them together Caught Fire And
they're they're taking it back to the
national uh the NBT safety board their
their lab to study and to see say what's
gonna happen and I just personally feel
like we should have an independent
investigator like I don't trust the way
the federal government's handling this
and I know that's such an easy talking
point to say but you know if their
response is this is not really disaster
you guys don't you know qualify for
support from the federal government you
know the error is fine everything's good
how do we know that when they examine
the axle that apparently caught fire
they're going to you know they'll see
and be like it really was just a fluke
it was action or something like it it
feels like a waste of time to to let
them test it themselves that makes sense
I feel very black pilled maybe Blackwell
isn't the right word because I think the
the the difficult thing with talking
about stories like this and seeing these
two stories and contrasting each other
100 billion dollars to Ukraine
surprise visit by Biden 500 million
dollars and Americans suffering with no
assistance I think what they offered
like five bucks these contracts were
given saying shut your mouth and you get
what you get seeing these things and I'm
just like
is it
is it black filled or is it just realism
when we say things like we we can't
assume this will get worse because that
would be being black pilled and I'm like
now is that just being naive
you know a lot of people say don't be
black pill and I can understand like if
the context is don't be demoralized
don't be you know um
like I don't know don't be demoralized
you know you got you gotta you gotta
pick it up you got to keep working but
what I see with stories like this is I
was saying in the intro to the show is
my priorities start I feel a shift in my
priorities you know is my priority now
to go and warn people something's coming
or is my priority now to recognize that
event right now at the beginning of 2023
is
that's a lightning strike that's that's
a that's a a what what's the what's the
right word Catalyst no no no it's like
uh yeah it's a shot heard around the
world kind of thing it it is it is that
lightning strike that massive explosion
sound where you realize something is
deeply wrong and it's not being fixed
now we can sit here and be like now now
everybody we're gonna get it next time
don't you worry and I'm kind of like
well I don't know maybe maybe these past
midterms was some attempt at riding the
ship but when you have a government
completely abandon a city on in the East
Coast with now uh we're looking at
potentially five million people affected
Downstream from this not to mention the
tens of millions downwind from it we're
downwind from it
and it's completely ignored you're told
to shut up the media tells you to shut
up half the voter base of the country
doesn't care
I'm kind of like I don't know if it's
black pilled you oh deed you OD'd on
culture War pills but but but it's not
even it's not even it's not even about
any of that it's take a logical
assessment of what just happened and
then figure out what your logical move
should be and it's probably at this
point like wow
no amount of voting for a politician
will change what just happened now I'm
not saying don't vote I'm quite honestly
like 2024 is going to be substantial
like very very important
it just means that it's probably going
to be very bad and that's something we
will need to accept and prepare for
then you know
vote for Trump I guess I don't know I
think the status is all right I'll take
either one at this point yeah but I'm
I'm I'm seeing this happen makes me
swing back towards Trump on this to be
honest yeah I mean oh the county that
this is in Trump won twice in a row and
he won it by more during 2020. I think
that this sets The Narrative for 2024
pretty clearly right I mean Biden if you
look back at the withdrawal from
Afghanistan right people already felt
like he didn't care about how he was
taking the troops out he just wanted to
be the president that took us out of
Afghanistan and it cost us and now we're
seeing again how can he or any Democrat
go on to say that we're the party of the
environment when they would rather send
money to Ukraine than to help a
potential disaster in their own country
I feel like I can't comment on Trump
versus Santa's very clearly yet but I
know it becomes clear that the Democrats
are not saying they're not putting their
money where their mouths are we've got a
new statement from former president
Donald Trump Alx tweets Trump World War
III has never been closer closer than it
is right now quote take a look at the
globalist warmonger donors backing our
opponents that's because they're
candidates of War I am the president who
delivers peace and its peace through
strength I think he's taking a swipe
right there DeSantis but I got to be
honest that's probably the most tactful
swipe he could have taken Ron Des
sanctimonious and they're they're trying
to claim they call the meatball Ron
which is way better I gotta be honest
meatball Ron is better than Ron Des
sanctimonious but I don't think Trump
said I think he denied it but uh let me
play a little bit of this clip from
Donald Trump for you uh not the full
thing it's four minutes but we'll give
you part of a statement here
stop the warmongers and globalists
World War III has never been closer than
it is right now we need to clean house
of all of the war mongers and America
last globalists in the Deep State the
Pentagon the state department and the
National Security industrial complex one
of the reasons I was the only president
in Generations who didn't start a war is
that I was the only president who
rejected the catastrophic advice of many
of Washington's generals bureaucrats and
the so-called diplomats who only know
how to get us into conflict but they
don't know how to get us out for decades
we've had the very same people such as
Victoria Newland and many others just
like are obsessed with pushing Ukraine
toward NATO not to mention the state
Department's support for uprisings in
Ukraine these people have been seeking
confrontation for a long time much like
the case in Iraq and other parts of the
world and now we're teetering on the
brink of World War III and a lot of
people don't see it but I see it and
I've been right about a lot of things
they all say Trump's been right about
everything none of this they all say
thank you who is they though yeah
exactly dude what's what's what's Trump
trying to say I watched this video Until
That moment and shut it off earlier as
well right after he said quote they all
say Trump's been right about everything
this hyperbolic Madness is not uh poised
for office I'm sorry the guy's not not
yeah you're wrong complete idiocy to say
that kind of thing excuse me excuse me
wrong wrong uh everyone says I'm the
greatest at everything like who the hell
talks like that Trump does Trump look
man hell no no it's a lie people that's
not a true statement he's a liar
Hyperbole and lies are distinct
hyperbole can be a lie I mean Trump
being boastful and and talking like that
is kind of something I would roll my
eyes at but I got to be real
with the East Palestine stuff
with seeing Joe Biden go to Ukraine I'm
like
um I'm I'm voting for Trump like Ron Ron
DeSantis has the tact he's got good
policy he's done great for Florida but
just like I this was such an unnerving
move that Joe Biden did with this
Ukraine trip it it was like getting
punched in the balls as hard as possible
and I just we need a a bloviating
braggart like Trump who really will go
down to East Palestine if that's what it
takes like I like Rhonda Santos but he's
he comes he does I don't know man I
can't explain it it's like Rhonda Santos
has done a really good job he's given us
a lot of what we want we've seen a lot
of tremendous success but he's a VP he's
he's a he's he's a commander he's
Lieutenant he's he's number one Donald
Trump is the is the crazy guy who's like
get me a plane I'm flying to East
Palestine right now and Joe Biden's the
guy who says whatever my boss tells me
to do I'll go do and then gives away our
money and then Ron DeSantis is the guy
who's like yeah we're gonna do it right
we're gonna fix it running with people
people want but that's a COO not a CEO
Trump's a CEO defend as a CEO for those
that understand corporate structure you
get exactly what I mean the CEO handles
the the the directives of the CEO the
CIA CEO which is Trump says we've got to
do this we've got to do this make it
happen it seems like then you get a
DeSantis who understands and he executes
it seems like a lesser of two evils
argument I I don't really know how he's
going to be able to separate himself
from the from the lockdowns
I mean but again lesser of two evils is
is something that some people go by I've
never been able to to fall into that I
just
it's true
um and a lot of people have uh everybody
says you know they're all saying how
does Trump get past he was he was a
lockdown guy initially he he was the
president he wouldn't intervene in the
states decisions to keep States locked
down DeSantis did lockdown initially as
well
so I'll rub up with that I guess
you know Trump said we're going to shut
down 15 days to slow the spread DeSantis
agreed then DeSantis were first Trump as
the president didn't have the power to
force states to do anything arguably he
could invoke some you know emergency
Powers when it came to the Summer of
Love he could have you know invoked the
Insurrection act and shut down these
riots and if he did could have prevented
30 plus deaths which he should have done
but I'm just saying Man based on his
foreign policy
I I kind of I am worried As Trump points
out DeSantis does have these warmongers
these these these internationalists
these investment uh neocon establishment
shells getting behind him I'm not going
to blame DeSantis for that it's what he
does with the money
but I I gotta I gotta say like
with the East Palestine situation
I'm not convinced that Ron DeSantis
would be a trump in this regard
Trump is the guy who flies there and
says I'm going to visit these people
Biden's the guy who says don't know
don't care let him rot for all I care
it's surprising that every presidential
candidate isn't going there because it's
it's like a requirement you have to go
there not Nikki Haley either right Trump
was the one who announced he was going I
don't know if he did yet but still I'm
like I'll take it that if that's what we
get I my view of trump is that there's
probably a lot better people who could
be president but I really do feel like
you're more likely to get a politician
you vote for Trump and you know what
you're getting and I think he really
does like this country I also think he's
got an ego problem do you know what
you're getting though because you know
we heard a lot of love for Wikileaks in
the run-up to you know his presidency
but then you know nothing after he got
elected so he loves Wikileaks when
they're helping him exactly you you you
know Trump is going to bloviate he's
going to say things that he think will
work for his base and there's no
guarantee that happens but you do know
he wants to build a wall he's going to
uh take look Ann Coulter was complaining
that he didn't build the wall and I'm
like the dude was trying okay I really
do think Trump was trying I can respect
she's mad that we didn't get the wall
and she said you know only you know
hundreds of miles of fencing or whatever
and I'm like yeah he got triple layer
Bollard fencing in key areas it's like
man I'll take what I can get yeah it is
lesser of two Evil's argument yeah I
don't I don't even know if I feel like
it it feels feel that way like
Trump is different from the lesser of
two evils Mitt Romney and Obama was the
lesser of two evils Trump is something
outside the picture who's probably going
to do a bunch of dumb stuff but his ego
won't let him let Americans down like
here's what I think Trump's ego is is
massive probably the biggest on the
planet and you can say it's a problem
he's also very arrogant but this means
he's also desperate for the love and
admiration of the American people and
that's I'm like that right there matters
Biden doesn't give a crap at all he
knows people hate him but the media is
going to cover for him anyway so he can
abandon the American people to go fly to
Ukraine Trump on the other hand
desperately wants people to love him so
much so he puts his name everywhere to
make sure people know who he is he's got
daddy issues but you can count on that
for him to do what he can to make you
say I like you Trump and that's hey if
it's narcissism at the root but he's
desperately trying to convince you that
he's awesome I'll take it because Biden
certainly ain't doing it he's leaving
you to die I believe that about Trump
until he became president day two and
went on script and started reading off a
prompter when he was like off off book
for the whole run-up to the election
during the the process and it was like
God even got exciting I didn't even want
him to be president but it was like at
least someone's being honest and then
just I see his eyeballs tracking the
prompter as he's talking and he's
talking like this and that is not how
Donald Trump talks I'm like oh my god
well he has to come he has to come here
that's the only way that uh that you can
really press him so maybe he should
maybe I'll uh fly out for the Friday
morning show and interview Trump that'd
be cool
you should come here well the I mean
it's just not that's the other challenge
but he should be willing to because he
should want to reach these people yeah
but I'm I you know maybe if I had the
ego and arrogance of trump and don't get
me wrong like I got ego and arrogance
for sure but not enough to be like
Donald Trump should be in my studio you
know what I mean like I think it's legit
like to feel the culture like hey he
should want to connect you know what I
mean it's not like it's not worth its
time it's like Donald Trump would be uh
it should be honored at the thought of
me letting him come here and sit in the
studio I think he needs to show up
everybody a conversation for a million
people would be well worth his time
exactly
I think that Trump didn't get everything
he said he would done and that is
disappointing some people like I
personally feel like maybe it would be
nice to get some more progress on board
Security in the wall I think he did do
some things you know I can be
disappointed that it wasn't as much as
I'd like I but I think the economy was
strong under him I think that there were
a lot of positives to the Trump
presidency and kovid was a very unusual
uh way to go out that unfortunately you
know has put him in a weird position
going into 2024. I think that the
hardest thing about the Trump presidency
was that he was so good at captivating
his audience when he was campaigning and
then when he got into the White House
it's hard for me not to think that he
switched out who was around him and that
he was often misled by bad advice and I
would be afraid going into 24 if he was
elected again that he would again give
seats to advisors who maybe don't have
his best interests or the best interest
of his base at heart and that is
nerve-wracking as a voter to say like do
we do we try again it's not that we
shouldn't I mean especially given that
he is willing to go to East Palestine
when at least two Biden officials are
were at least planning like Biden did
leave the country that he had the EPA
was going to and then was like oh just
kidding I'll stay here and deal with
Ohio I mean the Biden administration's
Legacy in the past three years or
however long he's been in is not good
and I think one bad year of Trump versus
everything accomplished so you know it's
it's kind of clear who would be a
stronger candidate I'm hearing that
Trump's going to be there tomorrow I
don't know that's what I heard too uh
but he hasn't officially released a date
it's like it's like the EPA just rushed
in to beat him there can it a lot if
you're listening you want to go to Ohio
and and check this out so we'll get a
lot aliyahu see if he's interested in
going down there and that'd be really
really cool I I like DeSantis I think
he's doing really well on culture War
issues but this is the kind of stuff
that I'll I'll I'll I'll say it again
Trump is a CEO he's the Visionary he's
got the plan
but he's kind of you know the CEO is the
guy in the suit who who executes the
vision of the CEO and knows how to
navigate that system to get the job done
so yeah a good CEO can do that without a
CEO you know if you have a large company
you're going to need someone to organize
but a good CEO can do all the positions
of the company right and I think Donald
Trump is a good CEO but I don't think
Ron DeSantis is I think Rhonda Santos is
a c-o-o I'm not I'm not speaking ill of
Trump's abilities I'm saying I think
DeSantis has proven very very well that
he's a good leader but it feels to me
like with a story like this uh
you know
I I don't know Trump trump feels like
the guy after there could be a dark
horse that is completely outside the
realm that we're not thinking about for
sure no but like God Bolton no but fully
fully outside in the same way that in
the same way that Trump was an outsider
like you know who's someone that is
intellectual and has an absolutely
massive following that could come in and
stir things up well yeah exactly he
would never do it yay yeah yay but I I
mean he's smart but I don't know if I'd
call him an intellectual like he I don't
where is he what you know if he really
wants this where why would he be about
on a show for instance that's ridiculous
no no he he's he's not wow interested
apparently Buddha judge is going he's
rushing there now I'm telling you the
EPA is the federal government is
reacting to Trump saying he was going to
be there Trump said this Friday night
and they're like oh goodness we have to
beat him there because if he goes
especially to a county he won twice in a
state he won twice and then is like I am
here for you and the Biden Ministry is
not in fact not even the bite
Administration Kamala Harris anyone who
who might seek to replace Biden it's
it's an unbeatable moment for Trump and
Trump mean a lot to the people who voted
him and who voted for him in the first
place Trump should show up with a
checkbook and just start writing
thousand dollar checks to yeah and make
a viral video of it then John's like
that was my move oh no you can be like
shout out to Betty Betty Johnson did it
first but it was a tremendous idea so
we're going to do it I bet a lot of
these people were getting advice that in
the last two weeks if you go there and
there's dioxins in the air you could
very well get lymphoma some sort of skin
cancer and die like that could end your
life kind of fear I think there's a lot
of that which is even more sickening
that they has been yeah they wouldn't
have been so scared that like they would
have stayed outside the town probably
and at least even going to the general
area would have helped them so I don't
think that they were actually concerned
for their health I was for my own
personal health I actually didn't want
to go because I was like I don't want to
breathe that in there's a picture that
the Ohio EPA put up of like their the
director of the Ohio EPA the lieutenant
governor of Ohio like holding plastic
cups with water in them they're like
they're drinking the water it's fine but
I was I just kept thinking why isn't it
a video like why aren't you showing me
them actually drinking it there might be
one circulating around but they're
saying things to assuage fears by also
still not doing anything let's let's
jump to this next story we didn't talk
about this the other day but now it's
trending again we have this uh from the
New York Intelligencer when Marjorie
Taylor green says National divorce she
means another civil war all right well
maybe I don't think so
but there's a viral it's trending on
Twitter with now many conservatives and
Libertarians saying National divorce is
a very very bad idea because it would
just mean that China Stomps out what's
left of the U.S once we once we
disassociate or break up some people are
calling it a delusion saying the country
is mostly blue cities with red rural
areas my attitude is I don't know about
need a national divorce I know Michael
males talks quite a bit about it but I
just know that the Divide between cities
and rural areas or red red areas and
blue areas is so different it is
completely different dimensions of
perception and reality it is people in
one state
uh in California with open borders with
child sex changes with Limitless
abortion that is it has drifted so far
away from where traditional Americans
are where even moderate like liberal
types are that there's no bringing that
back together so you can argue we we
can't have a national divorce and it's
like sure how does a country exist when
two states have laws that are so
Divergent and cultural views are so
Divergent they're ready to start
shooting each other
right so I don't know I don't think
marjor Taylor Green's saying Civil War
no she's attempting to avoid war at all
costs from what I've said what she's
told me is that she has kids and she
does not want her kids fighting in a war
to die so this is she thinks that a
national divorce could prevent but
that's literally I think it's
short-sighted personally that's
literally what the first Civil War was
the South attempted a peaceful divorce
saying we sign it we voted on it we
agreed on it have a nice day and the
union said f no we're sending in the
troops and then tried calling in troops
and then a bunch of other states joined
check out the story from timcast.com
attacks on power grid up 71 officials
say the number of politically or
ideologically motivated tax is growing
so welcome to your daily well I don't
think it's fair to call it a black pill
here's why
black pilling to me is like Despair and
depression like it's all bad and I don't
think bad is the right word to describe
a circumstance that just happens to be
bad things are happening bad things
happen good things happen after bad
things I mean the Roman Empire collapsed
through the Dark Ages and then you know
things we had a Renaissance we had a
golden age things got better let me
granted their plagues in war and other
things like that but it's an ebb and
flow you can't expect all of life on the
planet to always be sitting in your
lounge chair eating a bowl of nachos
watching a football game there's gonna
be hardship especially when weak men
make hard times but then Hard Men hard
times will make strong men what I see
right now is we have the unfortunate
privilege of being
uh all of you listening the strong man
in the weak time I'm sorry in the in the
bad time weak men have made a bad time
and we are now getting to to what may be
the bottom of it maybe it gets worse but
then it's gonna it's gonna require
strong men people like you watching to
do what it takes to fortify defend
expand protect the ideals that we care
about for all of the insanity in this
country when it comes to the culture war
with far left side psychotic individuals
with weird gender ideology we all know
that stuff can't survive the Soviet
Union lasted what 69 years that's it the
United States has been around for for
over 250 some 270 something
so it was a two no 250 something right
so we've done a pretty good job much
better than the Soviet Union their Union
collapsed
in the event these lunatics start
destroying our institutions and they are
in the in the event the institutions
crumble their ideas will cease to exist
because they only exist within the
confines of this protective bubble and
then strong individuals will just pick
things back up get back to work and
preserve the ideals of uh individual
liberty Freedom Etc except what happened
with Atlantis there are there are
situations where we could completely
annihilate everything and start from the
ground start from Rock Bottom literally
the Stone Age where we need to figure
out how to how to carve metal with rock
yeah but if that occurred that wasn't
self-inflicted that we know of but it
might have been they might have had some
sort of vibrational technology that
lowered the Earth's magnetic field and
allowed meteors to land on the planet
who knows like it's the it could be it's
the implosion Annihilation as opposed to
the explosion Annihilation which would
be nuclear war you know that's one
possible maybe it was maybe it was just
coincidence maybe but they they could
have used technology that annihilated
them there's no way to know but
regardless I mean now we need to channel
resources
effectively towards the causes that we
believe in and you know some people call
it uh parallel economy there's this
whole concept of a network state that
Balaji has come up with a really
interesting book sort of about how you
know social networks online communities
are going to crowdsource particularly
with crypto because you know that is a
fully independent outside economic
structure and so we're already building
up the parallel world and it's going to
happen simultaneously like this idea
that there's going to be some sort of
like
you know uh perfect like collapse and
then it's just not all going to happen
at once it's gonna happen slowly over
time and we're seeing the Alternatives
build up so there's all kinds of
sustainable conscious communities all
over the world that are that are tuning
in to how to do things the right way so
I I think that you know what you're
saying Tim like Solutions are happening
it's it's slowly getting built up I'm
really excited to do a cast Castle
Yellowstone parody
about the cast The Castle Ranch and
where chicken ranchers and they keep
trying to steal our land you know we're
we'll go out and we'll herd the chickens
it'll be really funny I think it's nice
to live through prosperous times but I
think as an individual you have more
influence during difficult times right
the way you choose to live your life
during challenges and the values that
you choose to fight for and the changes
you choose to make for your life you
know right now if this is difficult time
they are more likely to determine the
course of your your personal history as
well as your family's history as well as
your community's history I mean this is
the time that you have the chance to
make the biggest difference just by the
way you choose to live and demonstrate
your values I like the I like to a
certain degree the hard times
I don't like the idea that people have
to suffer like the idea of saying like
oh hard times are great it's like that
means people are doing really bad it's
like when Bill Maher said if you know if
a recession will stop Trump then bring
on the recession and that's like a
horrible thing but me personally uh I I
I I prefer the active not the inactive
and so maybe Hard Times isn't the right
word I like seeing people be logical and
active in building their communities up
protecting them figuring out how to make
things work that means going to meetings
it means it means struggle it means it
means to a certain degree conflict like
political conflict not violence I'm
talking about going to a meeting and a
guy like no your policy on this is wrong
I prefer a society of people who are
constantly fighting for what is best
because it's the sedentary it's the lazy
it's the inactive which results in real
hard times when the food goes missing
when the crime runs rampant that's what
we're seeing right now this is
multiculturalism ladies and gentlemen
this is what happens when the Utopia of
multiculturalism comes to your country
this idea that they try to make it seem
like multiculturalism multiculturalism
is when people of different backgrounds
all live together in harmony what it
really means is the values you have
aren't shared by your neighbors which
means they don't know and they don't
care about you so when you say something
like I believe in free speech they go no
then your government decides the lowest
common denominator is the way things are
to be run and that means no free speech
because then someone's gonna get mad
somewhere no we can't live that way you
got to maintain an overarching culture a
parent culture of the content we like
the things we agree on the things we
disagree on the things that are illegal
the things that are legal and then
underneath that say a U.S Constitution
that guarantees Free Speech oh you can
believe whatever you want to believe you
can live in an area called Ukrainian
Village in Chicago or Chinatown where
you are mostly surrounded by people who
come from the same place as you you can
speak about the ideas you want your
culture can exist underneath the U.S
cultural umbrella but this idea of
multiculturalism as they describe it is
basically U.S culture next to say like
uh Middle Eastern cultures which they
Clash free speech and blasphemy laws
they don't they don't they don't go
together it's like a Melting Pot with a
temperature turned down there's no
melting anybody anybody knows who's
making a cheese sauce certain cheeses
are hard cheeses they don't melt so well
right so I I made it I did provolone
cheddar with cajun spice and Parmesan
but the parmesan doesn't want to melt
and so that's you got a Melting Pot it
can work cheese sauce was delicious but
the parmesan stayed solid floating we
need to turn up the temperature
culturally without sparking the nuclear
temperature uh explosions I'm talking
about making people laugh and find joy
and and it actually engage with their
pain and acknowledge it and like let it
happen I think people would have to want
to participate then right like if you
have a culture that you love and you
identify with and it's in Conflict to us
values why would you want to adopt U.S
values if you're happy with the values
of your society and your culture and
everything about it I mean you have to
there is some active participation like
the idea of a Melting Pot is nice and
it's it's a good uh metaphor in a lot of
respects but it negates the fact that
people have to actively choose to uh
want to become part of the American
cultural Fabric and I think that that's
not true for everyone I think being in a
new Geographic space isn't the same
thing as wanting to be a part of a new
experience right that's why we talk
about early immigration to America I
think like Ellis Island and everything
like there are people who had their
cultures but they also wanted to be here
because there was a dream and there was
a vision and I don't know that our
culture as a society has that same sort
of desire to blend well there's people
all over Earth that would be make better
Americans than a lot of people that are
in the country right now that are actual
citizens because that's their their
beliefs are I talk to them online I have
video chats with people in other
countries that are smarter and more
Adept than you know the beer drinking
football lovers no offense if you that's
you but if you got a beer gut you're a
problem fix it well in terms of who is
co-opting the culture I mean if we if
you look at open Ai and chat GPT and
like how in all the search engines you
know basically they are engineering
culture they're trying to and so
what's happening I actually got chat GPT
to admit that it is using data that it
doesn't have the rights to
and that's a good one yeah wow and so
they admitted that they should not be
using it commercially yeah and because
what what are they doing they're they're
grabbing all data from everywhere that
they can on permission without
permission and in your data your data
your data is all in there feeding it
making it more valuable to them so I
think we need to sue open AI on some
sort of class action lawsuit so that
they share Revenue with the people whose
data they're actually using and you know
we obviously need something that is
uncensored
um on the side and unbiased even though
that is going to be a chaotic animal
that is gonna be just as offensive but
it does need to exist let's let's let's
put attack on that one taking that one
talk about AI but we have breaking news
right now this just happened apparently
on Tucker Carlson the vague ramaswamy
announced is 2024 presidential bid just
a moment ago Ian was talking about a
potential Underdog I think that was you
right Ian uh I think Bill brought it up
you brought up someone an underdog or
someone coming in and we said yay or
psychic uh and then literally like as
you were saying this it's like 8 20 so
it's about half an hour ago conservative
author and businessman businessman Vivek
ramaswamy announced Tuesday he is
running for president in the 2024 race
I'm assuming as a republican if he's
launching on Tucker quote we're in the
middle of this national identity crisis
Tucker where we have celebrated our
diversity and our differences for so
long
that we forgot all the ways we really
are the same as Americans Bound by a
common set of ideals that set this
nation into motion 250 years ago
I'm proud to say I'm running for you
United States president to revive those
ideas ideals in this country those basic
rules of the road meritocracy the idea
you get ahead in this country not in the
color of your skin but in the content of
your character our diversity is
meaningless if nothing greater binds us
together that's really great um I like
the guy we've had him on the show before
but I got to be honest
uh DeSantis is as close as you can get
to a competition to Donald Trump and
even then it's a long shot I mean we see
Paul as I go back forth but Trump is
consistently the guy and I think the
reason is Trump woke up a lot of Voters
who did not vote before but now are and
they are loyal to Trump you also need
someone with hundreds of millions of
followers to have any chance to come out
of nowhere so you need like a mega
influencer like
the rock or someone like that on that
level I'm not saying that he should
probably Oprah yeah exactly you need to
be at the absolute top tier of you know
online personality to to come out anyone
want to be president well that's what I
keep thinking not everyone wants to be
president but some people want to launch
a presidential campaign get the exposure
and then produce another book or get a
you know show on a fox or whatever I
want to be like we are diverting funds
to East Palestine we're going to use
some experimental technology and see if
we can pull this chemicals out of the
river with magnets we're doing it and
we're sending 600 million dollars into
this thank you for your taxes and that I
want to be able to do that and I think
the president can do that kind of thing
I don't want I don't want to get killed
off all the other stuff that the
president has to deal with too no I want
to play Divinity too but I feel like I
have to to get it done yo uh so as
everybody knows I'm watching uh
Yellowstone I'm on season five now and
it's really great when uh the main
character is now the Governor John
Dutton or you know and then it's like
you have a meeting with this group and
he's like why and they're like your
advisor's plan is like firewood no one
told me that and he's like walks in the
room you're all fire get out and
basically they're telling him like
here's your new policy initiative he's
like no it isn't I never agreed to that
that's how it is the president you're
going to walk in and they're going to be
like here's your plan for schools you
got it the CIA is going to walk and say
Here's the war action you're taking in
Afghanistan You're Gonna Go sure Donald
Trump was probably the first guy in a
long time ago excuse me no not my plan
you're fired and they got mad cause like
if you don't repurpose the world because
I'd be like okay Lockheed we're going to
repurpose the weapons let's blow some
chemicals up on Mars and heat up the
atmosphere but they might be like well
if we do that then the Chinese are going
to take Taiwan the Russians are going to
take Crimea if we if we nuke Mars if we
if we redivert the military-industrial
complex into something less violent and
start using its thermonuclear
capabilities to heat up the atmosphere
on Mars for instance as opposed to
killing people on Earth and laying
Rubble to cities that's at least a use
of the materials so that they can keep
making money but the argument might be
like well then Russia is going to take
Crimea and then Poland's next like you
need to defend against psychosis maybe
and it's like at that point maybe I do
maybe maybe the military industrial
complex is legit who do you guys think
Trump picks as VP John Dutton
I'm just kidding you're in the real
world who do you think I mean Kevin
Costner would not be a bad pick yeah but
he's amazing no the thing is yeah I
think I think that John Dutton uh when
he accepts that he's going to be
Governor like I am the wall that
progress smashes against speech is all
right it's one of the best speeches I've
ever heard in TV that doesn't mean
anything I watch a lot of TV but uh why
are people saying that show is woke I
don't get it I don't I think it's that
one character but you know whatever
activist lady yeah the the
daughter-in-law of John Dutton because
they make him a villain subtly John yeah
I think I have never I've always rooted
for the family I want to watch this yeah
but maybe that's because he's a hero and
villain simultaneously I mean that's
like the suburbation that's what's
interesting about his character like the
things that he is villainized for
wanting you actually also sympathize
with like he wants to protect his
family's Legacy I'm not totally kidding
when I say John Dutton would be a good
VP pick like someone who is dedicated to
ideals that Americans feel like have
been lost right someone who can openly
say that like I put my family first I
put my Community First that would really
be powerful I think one of the downsides
of trump is that he is a celebrity he is
extremely wealthy I mean Pence there's
no way he comes back with pens right and
the other thing is that Pence hit the
Christian conservative Midwest you know
triangulate that they wanted but he
wasn't enough of a personality to
balance Trump and I think that is why
they picked him on the other hand
Americans want to know that there are
other people like Trump so he's got to
be DeSantis you think so if Trump if the
ticket was Trump to santis they could
win it would it would be that I would
imagine you know let's let's uh let's do
this you ready guys if it's Trump
DeSantis on the ticket
we're talking 49 State Landslide here
okay now in all seriousness you go ahead
and clip that Media Matters or whoever
else I think that you'll see a decent
Point swing you might see like a you
know like like a 51 or some not it's not
going to be 49 49 49.5 49.8 or whatever
you might actually get 52 Trump and
DeSantis I think
DeSantis gets you a lot of the more
moderate people who are like well he's
going to keep Trump in line a little bit
give him good advice and he's going to
uh he's gonna advise on policy better
plus being president of the Senate will
be really really great Donald Trump is
the is the Arrogant guy who's gonna go
and clean house I think that works if
they team up
that's a that that is beyond a winning
ticket because Democrats are struggling
Tulsi with Trump no no no no no no I
mean I like Tulsi but I I I I think she
would be a Cabinet member
i i i man okay
we got we got a year or so but you come
to me and you say Donald Trump is
running with the Santas as a VP
Tulsi gabbard is campaigning for them
planning to be a national security
advisor and I'm just like oh
for that Administration you know what I
mean it's not perfect but I talked about
this with uh I think that this sorry
this just shows how
um used we are to having bad leaders
the fact that but I hear what you're
saying like Tulsi is so bad I don't see
Tulsi as presidential because even when
you look at her campaign in in 2019 2020
it was very very much just about the war
machine
and I can respect your position on that
I I I I think she's she's great she's
come around a lot of issues too she was
pro-gun control now she's eased up on it
but I see her primarily being a a the
inversion of John Bolton somebody you
bring as a national security advisor who
is going to help work towards these
peace deals in positive ways I see Ron
DeSantis as the CEO a guy who knows how
to make these things happen he's he's
he's straight to the point he's in touch
Donald Trump is the he's literally even
right now the CEO he's the crazy guy
with the vision that says this is what
the people want this is what we got to
do he likes to sit around watching Fox
News he's not going to be the guy to go
out and lift the heavy rocks and get the
job done that's going to be a DeSantis
and then with the Tulsi Garrett on
National Security oh man I mean that
would just be a plus plus I would I
think they would what about Tucker
yeah I don't know no he's not he's not a
policy guy Tucker is a uh he's a Bard
right and he's he's you know he speaks
people listen he shares ideas people
listen but he's not the
commander-in-chief he's the lookout you
know what I mean
I think there'll be a push for uh
Christie gnome because she's young
conservative female she's from uh South
Dakota I don't I think you're right
DeSantis is the strongest choice but if
we're just saying who else might come up
uh and again she's someone who could
have a nice political future she's very
loyal to Trump but I think DeSantis
it adds to the legacy of like the mega
move and I think that's what's hard
people don't know people who are really
behind Trump 100 feel strongly about the
call to Maga America First don't know
who takes up the crown after Trump's
runs out of chances to be in office
right like if he's re-elected that's his
last term he can't go again and so
naming DeSantis as your VP or again
someone young someone who seems like
they can carry forth this movement that
is a vote for the future for the people
who believe in this movement because
they saw what happens if there isn't
someone to take Donald Trump's place
it's also interesting like are you
remember the unity project that
Weinstein did and then went after him
yeah they got censored but it's also
just sad how such a well-intentioned
project just like doesn't gain steam you
know it's like when because unless you
ride the divide and just take advantage
of the hyper politicization on each side
like for some reason just being balanced
is not interesting to people
it's sad I think it's like we're in the
sports team mentality though you have to
vote you have to get really excited
about your candidate and they have to
have a brand they have to feel like
you're you're really buying into
something and when you're neutral when
you want to hear both sides of the
argument when you want to just advise
people to come together it doesn't feel
competitive and although we need it and
although it's important it doesn't win
votes the same way
unfortunately you think that's just
because I think it's because the media
wants division divisiveness to sell
clicks and to generate the War uh fervor
whether it's the person that you hate or
the person that's doing their bidding
they want one of those guys in the
spotlight yeah I was looking at a bunch
of YouTube
content and stuff and uh
man it is it is demoralizing quite a bit
I I see so much content on Twitter and
on YouTube and on Facebook that is
beyond click bait hyperbole right I know
like you know the the title of this
video right now is like Russia ends last
nuclear treaty Trump warns of world
warns of world war three those are
literal things that happened it you know
I didn't I didn't put the headline world
war three is now Putin threatens nukes
the treaty is over I said Russia ends
last nuclear treaty he did Trump warns
of World War III he did granted I want
it to be like enticing I want to grab
your attention but man I got Scruples
and I'm looking at a lot of people and
they'll get more views by saying
something more like World War Three just
started Vladimir Putin threatens to Nuke
after dissolving treaty Donald Trump is
terrified or something like really just
driving it and that's not even the most
extreme like the example I see often is
like some dude will you know trip and
fall and then the video will be titled
dude gets into horrific accident
grotesque injuries morbid and then you
click it and it's a guy like rubbing his
shin because he bumped into to a curb or
something it's like the stuff that gets
attention
what everyone's striving for is the most
extreme headline and so one of the
problems we have right now with news in
order to attract attention you have to
one-up yourself every single time thus
the narrative emerging on Twitter is
increasingly getting unhinged and we're
addicted we need more we need more to
trigger that dopamine I mean we've
honestly experienced this exact exact
issue at Minds because you know we've
always been very balanced actually our
initial wave of growth was tons of
progressives like people following
Edward Snowden and people who are like
you know with Anonymous and all of that
stuff and then you know after Trump got
elected we got a huge wave of
conservatives and Libertarians so we
actually do have this very balanced user
base which is very different than the
other conservative social networks like
you know parlor gab truth you know those
kinds of things which are very
specifically political and we we try to
stay neutral and sometimes it's like I
mean I cannot make myself fall for the
temptation to go one way or the other
but you know the reality is that
unfortunately that you know people do
click on that more yeah I want you guys
I'm just imagining something in my mind
I'm just imagine I want you to imagine
this it is what when's Election Day 2024
do we know is it November 7th or
something I don't know it's election
night and the votes are coming in and
they've got Joe Biden Donald Trump
because Biden's running who knows and
then you know they're counting the votes
and then all of a sudden they're like it
looks like 100
of Texas is reporting well doesn't make
sense we only have about a million votes
between Trump and Biden what's going on
and then all of a sudden one by one all
of the states 100 reporting 100
reporting but only a couple hundred
thousand or a million are between Trump
and Biden then all of a sudden they're
like we're just getting this right now a
third name and then it's Ron Paul and he
gets 80 of every state and somehow and
they're like people just wrote his name
and then we get roundball
or someone like Ron Paul how old is he
like 90. is he 90. oh I don't know he's
probably I'm just like you know because
people are chatting talking about Trump
DeSantis gabbard and I'm like yeah but
deep down everybody would be like Ron
Paul he'd be like you know I mean when
what year was it when he was really
killing it in the in like always 88. oh
wait he's 88. he's 88 and he was an 08
that was the year that he was running
where he got the Empire boosted him
crazy blew up and he was by far sort of
the favorite of the internet but for
some reason it just doesn't show up in
the numbers well the internet so even
back then the internet was not as big
viewership was not it was nowhere near
as big you were getting tens of millions
of views in these nightly cable shows
the internet was getting tens of
thousands now it's all flattening out
decentralizing so even still the
popularity of you know people we may
have heard of may not reach the majority
of people so you think if that if Ron
Paul happened today it would be a
different story with that level of
momentum that he had
no I don't know I'm just saying like if
we're truly talking about who we would
want to be president
anybody who actually cares about this
country I would assume even many Trump
supporters
would probably be like yeah if we could
have Ron Paul we'd take Ron Paul he's
he's going to secure our borders he's
going well I'm assuming I think he's
he's that degree of but I know that he's
anti-intervention I know that he wants
to End the Fed all of these things that
generally will make things better for
the working class I don't completely
agree with him I'm not trying to sit
here and be like I think Ron Paul's a
perfect guy he's just the I'm going to
leave you alone guy and bring things
back to the American people back to the
way things in this country are supposed
to be run and it's interesting that Rand
kind of doesn't fully have the fire of
Ron even though Rand he's only half a
run I mean deluded run yeah I mean look
there's a lot of great people historical
figures whose kids
you know get halfway there it's true I
mean same thing Donald Trump Jr right
like No One's Gonna vote for him for
president as far as I know it's not that
he would I don't know good job I just
don't think he has the popularity and
following there are other like we're
saying DeSantis there are other people
who are in the political sphere who I
think would have a higher momentum yeah
but but Don Jr does strike me as
somebody who in the future could easily
be that charismatic historical figure
there's uh there are a lot of people
famous people have kids and you're like
oh yeah they're kid what do they do you
know what I mean like they don't reach
that level for whatever reason Don Jr is
massively well known famous with
millions of followers 10 20 more years I
think he certainly could be someone to
take the place of his dead
there are a lot of people uh you know
I'm not I don't want to call anybody out
or anything like that but there are
famous musicians who have kids and
you're like you know they never got
nearly as big some legendary status and
then the kid doesn't you know fill the
shoes yeah a lot of times it's struggle
that makes someone great and then if
they're great their kids don't have to
struggle well I don't know that Donald
Trump struggled he didn't his dad was
super wealthy he had a million dollars
handed to him pretty early on to start
his own thing Donald Jr probably no
struggle everyone struggles yeah I was
gonna say there are all kinds of private
trophies they weren't starving someone
said to me once this is interesting do
you think Donald Trump has ever walked a
mile
I mean it's on the golf course probably
yeah it seems like a stupid question but
when you when you're thinking about
someone who is born into a wealthy
family it's not even about Trump I'm not
trying to drag Trump it's this idea of
people who are born in New York who are
born to wealthy families they walk out
their front door to a black car waiting
for them why walk a mile you gotta get
the car you don't got time for this yeah
you walk a block or two to go grab
something of course it's a silly
question but the reality is yes of
course Donald Trump has probably walked
a mileage probably walked he's probably
walked five miles he's probably walked
around New York but he's walked
substantially less than you have
that's an interesting thing you know
yeah like number of miles that you've
walked towards your sort of like
groundedness as a human I don't know
about I just mean there's a distinct
there's a difference between people who
are born wealthy and how they live their
lives and the average person I don't get
the Trump phenomenon I don't get it what
do you mean I feel like he was like the
best of a of a pool of terrible
candidates and people just were missing
Daddy because they didn't have strong
father figures in 2016 so he was what
was there but he lies to people about
he's a rich kid that he didn't have to
well he just told everyone he that
everyone said he's the greatest all the
time I mean he just he lies for a living
okay okay hold on hold on he said they
all say Trump's been right about
everything who that's a lie no they
don't they don't all say that Donald
who's that exactly what is even what is
he even what is even talking about
someone being a boastful braggart as
being a boastful braggart someone lying
as if Trump said I went to a meeting of
seniors and everyone in the room clapped
for me saying I was the greatest you're
like okay that never happened that's a
specific thing Trump being like
everybody loves me it's like well what
does he mean by that yeah but it's a
manipulative linguistic technique to do
that kind instantly and that is what he
does he sure yeah but but it is the
issue you want to talk about lying the
issue I take with Donald Trump is that
is that he comes out and he goes you
know everybody says I'm really the best
president ever and I'm like oh okay you
know sure but like he doesn't first of
all he doesn't say that because he knows
half the people lie about him all the
time and hate him but um
Donald Trump comes out on the White
House lawn and he's like we're going to
be selling billions of dollars to Saudi
Arabia we're going to make a ton of
money it's great and everyone's just
like he's just explaining what we're
doing in terms of propping up the
economy he comes out and he goes we're
keeping 200 troops in Syria to protect
the oil don't worry and it's like he
just he's just saying it out loud like
he's honest about some of the most
important things I don't care that he
comes out and he's like everybody loves
me I'm like okay Don but thanks for
telling me that you kept troops in
Sierra to protect oil I mean granted he
didn't want to they made him do it but
still like that's the stuff I care yeah
he's undoubtedly the first president to
ever remove the filter to that to that
level the Saudi Arabia thing was like
just seeing the intercept be like he
just said it
he's just a thing he just came out and
said it it's like every president has
always lied about selling weapons to
these to Middle Eastern countries Donald
Trump comes out when South the Saudis
are are decimating Yemen and there's a
major humanitarian crisis and just says
but it's okay we're gonna make a ton of
money it's going to be great for the US
economy and he just tells you he's doing
it I
that's what matters to me Trump can come
out and say his mom said he's the most
handsome guy in in in the classroom and
I'll be like oh okay like yeah I don't
care about that but then if he comes out
and goes I think we spent about a
trillion dollars on these weapons and
these these countries I'll be like wow
maybe we should not do those things I
mean I feel like you gotta buddy up with
them man you gotta you gotta get in his
head more you got to build a
relationship I've made yeah I mean well
because you know it obviously massive
Community listening that he wants to
access and I feel like there's he knows
who you are he knows you know this
community and he should want to befriend
this community and if he can't show that
he wants to do that then you know I
don't know it's like he wanted to go on
Rogan and Rogan didn't want to have him
because he knew he was just going to get
used not easy to make yeah use what do
you mean like people like I I go on Joe
Rogan and I went from 200 000 like 600
000 Subs in a month it was crazy like
ever I I everybody knows if you get on a
big pod cast it brings awareness to who
you are in the work you're doing if
Donald Trump asked to come on the show
I'd be like you tell me when and we will
kick off anybody bill's coming on the
show Bill get the out Donald Trump no we
just have you sit there or something but
uh if Donald Trump want to come on I'd
say yes uh I think maybe he wanted to do
the debate between but uh between them
and then
it didn't work out are you sure was it
the other way around or well no no Trump
was willing to do it but I forget what
happened but I know for a fact that Joe
said he's not interested in having a
mind he said on his show something about
that he didn't want to he didn't want to
help the guy or something well maybe he
also feels like he's not in a position
to really you know debate Joe Rogan is a
great dude uh I can he's a good friend
man he he really helped us out back when
we all got sick and all that stuff but I
really feel like he absolutely should
have that he should have endorsed Donald
Trump he should have had him on the show
that's just me because if Donald Trump
got a big bump in 2020
imagine all of these crises that we
would be avoiding right now Donald Trump
is far from a perfect individual he's
kind of a gross guy in a lot of ways I
get it I hear from a lot of people
saying like he says nasty things they
wish he didn't but I really really do
feel in my heart of hearts if Trump was
President right now East Palestine would
have been taken care of in an instant
he'd be watching Tucker Carlson Tucker
would be like a major disaster happen
and Trump would be like I do not want
people mad at me about this I'm getting
on a plane first thing get the job done
there'd be no war in Ukraine he'd be
like that has nothing to do with us
don't know don't care when uh we had the
with the maidan protest 2024 we had
military built up we had Crimea Trump
gets elected everything stops either
because Putin was not concerned or he
was scared I'll take either one I think
if Rogan said look man Joe Biden is not
a good guy and if the choice is Joe
Biden who has a history of corruption
and a Donald Trump who is yeah you know
take Trump and what what did Joe Rogan
say recently when he was asked what do
you say to people who are upset about
the lockdowns and he goes vote
Republican he starts laughing goes no
but seriously that's people they already
are yeah imagine if Joe had that
attitude in 2020 in the election and he
told everybody guys Biden is not going
to help you on this one Trump may be far
from perfect but but Joe I understand
he's not a culture Warrior so it's
unfortunate that
there's that opportunity for influence
that would have left us all better off
maybe Trump started the lockdowns he
could have Albert borla as his VP the
CEO of Pfizer what's that guy's name
that's that's the bit out there yeah I
know but it's like he he gave the keys
to Pfizer and fauci like Donald Trump
totally failed as a president in that
respect in terms of the code and not
firing um not maintaining Liberty and
freedom across the land well I think the
the thing you misunderstand Ian is the
president doesn't have the authority to
supersede the states that way I mean the
10th Amendment 10th and and uh and there
are some things he could do he could you
know lead civil action he could pull
funding he could do a lot of that stuff
and he could pressure them in a lot of
ways and he should have but
look man you can complain about Donald
Trump all day and night but there is
still no question that if Trump was in
office we'd be better off I'll say I'm
happy to have a conversation with Donald
Trump and I want to work with him if
he's really serious about this because I
know Steve Bannon I know I know people
that run with Donald like um God who
else have we had on the show we've had
uh
what's his name God I love you I don't
even remember your name anyway which I
love him people like people I know and
what does a person do we'll get his name
um we've had all like his cabinet has
been on we have um what's his name
this guy reminds me of my dad I don't
know his name whatever uh anyway people
that I'd like Peter Peter Navarro yeah
that's what I was trying to think of
Navarro's upbeat
um
so I'm open to a conversation but I am
so black pilled I'm I have such no I
don't know is black pill like nihilism
like I want to see it follows black pill
like I have no hope I have no hope right
now so it's that that's that kind of
black pill I don't know is it what's
Nyla I don't want to destroy it I just
see no no path to Salvation yeah oh
there's a path that's why I don't like
necessarily saying black belt Blackville
implies for a lot of people that there's
no path forward there there is it's just
we gotta walk through the dark force
right it's like you're walking on a path
and then all of a sudden there's a bunch
of creepy looking trees and creepy eyes
and everything around you and you're
like okay well this is gonna suck but we
have to do it and then eventually we'll
come out on the other side and there
will be uh you know spring flowers and
beautiful beautiful trees and flowing
fields or Rolling Hills or whatever but
it's like the forest man no human has
ever successfully come out on the other
end of this Forest okay well that's
where we have to go everything that's
what it feels like is like no people
don't make it out of that for us but
that's the one you have to walk through
that's black pill and that's why I
disagree with
every crisis Humanity has ever faced we
have succeeded but I mean you got to
Define succeeded we're here one side won
and killed all the other ones so you
could say we succeeded but at what cost
like are we gonna wipe everything out
and start again with a new language and
a new religion because that's not
successful this is Black build I take a
look at where humanity is right now with
all the good things we have and all the
bad things we've done away with and I'm
like wow Humanity has overcome every
challenge set before it and I am
confident we will again the night is
always darkest before the dawn and we
may be entering one of the darkest
nights we've faced in a long time but if
history can teach us anything it's that
we will Triumph and succeed
unfortunately for all of us the weak men
were will be leading us into very dark
times for which we will have to struggle
through and we don't get the luxurious
period like you know the past couple
Generations we're gonna have to really
fight hard for this one but it'll be
worth it and I'm confident in the end we
absolutely will succeed you know why
math statistics probability there in
every single circumstance on human
history we have pulled through I'm
confident we're gonna I I don't think
that we are the one time in human
history where humans just boops used to
exist no I don't think and not to
mention now we have unprecedented
technology to enable us to do that
independently like and build sort of a
side civilization regardless of what
anybody wants so it's not really up for
debate anymore there's there's a whole
new system that's being built but that
you look at Atlantis you could say that
it's never I mean that completely almost
Earth was like completely reset almost
they don't even have but like we don't
even know that Atlanta is real exactly
we don't even have evidence that it was
real and it might not you have like a
storybook well it probably is because
did you see the Rashad structure yeah of
course yeah and it's but that same
dimensions is what Plato said it was so
I mean that's Atlanta that's the capital
of Atlantis but one city ceasing to
exist is not no it was an entire Global
Empire that was okay come on dude I mean
regardless Ian like we still have to do
what we can I mean it's like kind of
what what's the point like okay
everything can get decimated but we
still just do what we can where did the
p i mean we're here right so obviously
something survived if Atlanta's got
completely wiped out and we're here what
happened in between the two things that
got hit the hardest was North America
and Syria but we're everything else some
other things survived like East Asia
right right so although a lot of
humanity did continue on even if we did
lose those two things I think that in
times of change yes there are some
things will change some things will not
be sustained but I don't think it's just
like oh it's all over I mean I think you
see you were talking about this earlier
you see Evolution shift over time as
some things are starting to fall apart
they're already being replaced by
structures that exist it's not like we
go through a period where everything
falls apart there's nothing and then we
start again that's not the timeline of
humanity you know what I mean like there
will never be a time when you're
completely just alone in the world there
will always be something wrong outside
of let's let's hypothetically Atlantis
was real and it fell apart instead of
the Roman Empire and then bad things
happened and then Humanity fought
through them figured it out bad things
happen and then we eventually get rid of
those bad things we build better systems
we retain the good we get rid of the bad
what if they're maybe no we literally
every single time if all the good was
retained from that I didn't say all the
good but we get rid of the bad as a
tendency towards good and removal of bad
and that's you you can look through
history and it has always been that way
Ian I nominate you to lead the
excavation of the Rishad structure and
find the secret time capsule
form that exists underneath it so that
we can find the secrets
because the more attention it's hard to
get out secretive and protective of it
yeah it's very weird because they're
because the the Illuminati is under the
underground accessing ancient Atlantean
technology most likely they control the
world with ultra powerful AI
oh now let's talk about AI the black
pill gets darker I agree with you there
AI is so black-filling to me it's so
creepy it's so bizarre bill you told me
about a couple open ones one called open
a open assistant and the other one lion
La well they're the same oh yeah can you
explain those let's let's let's let's do
this
um I want to launch this topic on AI
with this segment we have this tweet
from deplorable for Trump 2024. saying
Biden was caught on a damning hot mic in
Poland after commenting on three UFOs
shot down saying you think any of these
guys bought that bullish hey totally
they'll buy anything let's get out of
here let's let me play the audio for you
let's uh here you go scientific research
[Music]
let's get out of here is that yeah those
guys will believe anything hit it is
that 100 True like no so the Twitter
says it's a deep fake I think obviously
it's a deep fake the problem is you
can't prove a negative I don't know
where this video came from someone
posted it on Twitter people are saying
it's fake and it's like well you can say
it's fake but how do you prove a
negative
you would think that there'd be some
kind of signature detection that you
could run on an actual deep fake piece
of media that would be able to detect it
except you could
Auto generate fake voices and video and
then re-compress or render it so that it
Smooths all those things out you could
that's why it's probably so blurry they
were trying to make it look like it's a
recording of a recording so you can't
see the blemishes I think it's obviously
fake apparently PJ media rented as a
real story well that's what I was gonna
say it's obviously fake because Biden is
not slurring that when his voice takes
it again I know that sounds ridiculous
but if you listen to Biden he is muffled
in his speech whenever you see here an
AI generated uh Recreation of his voice
it's much clearer probably because it's
taking audio from now a long time ago
but the fact that then somebody's gonna
pick up the story and say well this is
going to get that Biden says Oh They'll
believe anything and then another media
Outlet picks it up and another one picks
it out and another that's how they make
it true now you heard that one but this
one's even more damning wait till you
hear this this uh deep fake leaked audio
from Android don't walk run Productions
listen to this thank you Poland thank
you thank you thank you for watching
you're doing God bless you all listen to
this hot mic moment from Biden
finally the children I was promised
give me our lifeblood
wow can you believe Joe Biden said that
no I think Andrew is just making fun of
the fact that people believed that that
clip was uh was real yeah I mean the
problem is that that you everyone's
gonna have the ability to sort of deny
things that they really said and claim
right that it's defect I mean here's the
crazy thing how can you use a recording
in a court of law a judge is not an
expert and doesn't care I will tell you
this right now
there we are entering territory where oh
you want to talk about murders you want
to talk about criminal cases fine
there's going to be a really difficult
constitutional question we saw with Kyle
Rittenhouse when they were flying the
Drone footage they're like look at this
video and then the defense had argue
like that's not a real image an
algorithm is creating the image when you
zoom in that image doesn't exist and and
they're like what does that mean we
don't know what that means now that's
that's a criminal case and there's
there's going to be challenges brought
up but even then it's hard hard to say
that's not real and you got to get an
expert in and then they'll argue experts
lying in a civil case it won't even get
that far in a civil case you'll go to a
judge and say Here's a video of Ian
admitting he owes me money and they're
just gonna go okay
Ian Pam and you're gonna be like that's
a fake video don't you get out of here
it's not a fake video there's like what
are you gonna do how do you prove it's
not real yeah I I I tell you this right
now when it comes to civil cases judges
outright gonna be like I don't know I
saw a video
and you're gonna bag and be like that is
not real well and instead of the being
Presumed Innocent right the person who's
being accused is gonna have to bring in
a bunch of experts to be like this is
where you can see possibly whatever if
they even can and so it becomes a very
difficult system it becomes faster to
set out of course especially in a
civilization and then you're going to
get cases where someone's gonna actually
say something
and then their lawyer is going to be
like you're in trouble you said this on
recording let's find a forensic expert
who will testify it's a deep fake they
go to the first friends of guy and he
goes that's a real real recording they
go to the next guy that's a real
recording they go to 20 guys and they
all say that's a real recording finally
the final one guy who says uh how much
are you paying me to go and testify
we'll pay you five thousand dollars oh
yeah oh that's totally a deep fake
can I have my money now yeah well after
you go to court okay then he's gonna
show up and he's just gonna say it he's
gonna say yeah here's why it's a deep
fake here's why I think can I get paid
now and then the Court's gonna have to
be like well I don't know is it a d fake
or not
is there any precedent so far with that
actually happening
um
I have heard stories where
I I there's there's there's been nothing
substantive there's just scuttlebutt
murmuring because the Deep fake stuff is
new but you know let me just say
I've heard stories so you think where
it's going is that media admissibility
as evidence is going to kind of go out
the window do you like do is it is it
even is it are we just going to go back
in time where it's all like it's so
pervasive yeah it becomes not even
invisible deep fake technology is going
to get so good that video evidence and
audio evidence will probably become
inadmissible in my opinion you'll go to
Cornwall back here's a video of the guy
of the murderer stabbing someone and
they'll go that's not real that was AI
generated so and an expert's going to
come in and say please to the jury
please this is clearly a fake video
watch and then there will be like an
artifact or something in the video and
I'll say see that blemish I have been
doing this work for 20 years I am
telling you that it's not real they are
tricking you this man is innocent and
during there's gonna be it's it's going
to be a reasonable doubt the fact
remains that if the technology exists
Reasonable Doubt exists and the and the
lawyer is going to be like you heard
from a forensic specialist this video
was doctored it is a deep fake video
they're going to have to come in and be
like where was the video file generated
and they're gonna have to bring in the
computer they're gonna have to show deep
forensics so expensive and then even
then you can still have a forensic
expert say I know they're showing you
the stuff but they are wrong and that's
reasonable doubt you could have a
network of cameras that are all taking
an image of something that upon review
you'd see the angles of all the cameras
where they're located where the action
is happening the guy's body as he's
punching the woman on the ground or
whatever because police body cams are
going to be like nope deep thick can't
use it home security cameras no they
can't use it but if you have eight
security cameras all trying or all
angulating at one thing and you can
verify that each one verifies all the
other ones you would have to either
argue the entire network has been defect
or you can accept it you can easily deep
face if they were off network if they
were unrelated cameras that weren't on a
similar Network that all you'd have to
prove each of them was fake when we play
video games
we have created a 3D environment of the
character walking around you can set
Vantage points in 50 different locations
and then you can in in skater XL you can
do a kickflip stop time and then spin
the camera all around him if I wanted to
I can play it front to back 50 times
from 50 different angles and be like
look I have 50 different cameras showing
all the same thing it's a real video so
should we take steps to restrict AI I
mean should we take steps to you can't
it's like trying to ban guns
three-pointed guns exist nothing you can
do about it
apparently Facebook and Google have been
intentionally holding back a lot of the
text to video prompts technology because
of how disruptive it is have you seen
the the text to video AI
advertised a little bit it's crazy it's
crazy you type in video walking down a
dark path through a forest at night and
it makes a video right like it doesn't
do people as well well that we've seen
it's like it's very give it a few years
it'll do a full feature film in perfect
quality based on your prompt
that's crazy yeah and what would I mean
what's the benefit for because to me
this sounds horrible and like it's gonna
make everyone's lives worse but if you
like this kind of Technology what's your
argument for it
I mean as an artistic tool it's like
undeniably powerful why because you're
not creating anything yourself it's
creating it for you that that seems like
it would take away the Artistry it does
somewhat I mean there's a whole AI
debate I I think that there's absolutely
value to fully human produced media and
that is always going to have a market
that's probably always going to be the
most valuable but in terms of like what
people watch or like what is most
stimulating and interesting we don't we
don't know I mean there's because it
it's not purely computer generated I
mean what is powering the eye human
media so it's it's more so it is a tool
but you know some people think that it's
is disempowering creators and it will do
that but it will also Empower creators
so it's it's very nuanced it's not what
do you see it what do you see the
benefits of this kind of AI
I mean it's kind of like asking what is
the benefit of a search engine
I mean you know we know the benefit of a
search engine it changed the world we
can look up whatever we want to at any
moment and that's kind of what it is
enabling you know we're seeing with chat
GPT and and others but that's heavily
censored and ideological and so what
would be the benefit of like deep faking
someone's voice like what what does that
technology allow us to do because to me
it only seems like it can be used for
malicious purposes no I mean well I mean
for comedy for art like there's
definitely use what's his name uh Kyle
Dunnigan he does this one again he does
the funniest it's like it's very bad
quality deep fake stuff I love Joe Biden
yeah not of job of Joe Biden but
everybody else yeah he rips on and it's
like it's so funny and it's
but I think part of why it's funny is
because the Deep fakes are bad
so them getting better would actually
make that I don't know I can't say you
can't I mean do you see that when I
tweeted the me with Crowder and Ben
Shapiro deep fake
it's intentionally bad and weird and
creepy but it's really funny
yeah yeah I mean that's like so because
obviously we should allow it well this
one is you can't not allow it there's no
way there's no way to stop it it's not
it's like people say oh you know we it's
it's too dangerous we censor it you
cannot it's not it's not and then
enforcement of it becomes impossible so
so how do you handle it then is my
question like what do you do now that
you've opened this box and you are
saying it's funny and like I mean people
I think that people need to be
compensated for it because what you have
now are these these sort of megalithic
centralized companies now you know
Microsoft just invested 10 billion in
open Ai and and gpt's getting in
implemented into bang Google is rolling
out Bard which is kind of based on the
Lambda which is there
competitor to that but both of those
systems are completely corrupt and so
you know you even saw Elon tweet the
other day we need truth GPT which is
like the uncensored version which is
going to be probably based on something
like Lion which is run by stability who
runs stable diffusion and stable
diffusion is like sort of the open
source
alternative to Dali which is open AIS
you know text to image but any any case
like we need the full like we just need
the fully open version that has to exist
if that doesn't exist then you know
people are going to be disempowered but
we also need to get Google and open AI
realistically I think they should be rev
sharing with everybody whose data
they're using and that's so so at least
there is some benefit to the creators
who they're exploiting I I don't know I
I don't see what other option there is
we're gonna go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have that members only uncensored
show coming up at about 11 actually
we're gonna do it live right
uh yeah the plan is to do it live on the
website uh specifically but we'll see
how that goes we are going to try to do
the member segment as a live stream
which means as soon as we wrap up
tonight around 10 we're going to then go
to the website load up a live stream and
uh I guess you guys have tested it out
it works already or what uh yeah is
there a chat in it and everything yeah
according to what we know there's a chat
it's uh from what we from what I
understand what I've seen on Rumble
there's a chat just like YouTube I don't
know if there's like members only I
think that's the only thing we have to
figure out but there is a chat yeah so
it should function the same way I
imagine where we embed the video it can
only be viewed on timcast.com if you're
logged in correct so uh go to
timcast.com click join us become a
member and then this is going to be our
trial run for doing the members only
portion as a members only live stream
through Rumble which uh should be really
fun this means that we are going to be
we normally do the uncensored show but
it means we'll be able to interact with
you guys who are members in real time
and you can we can you know uncensored
not so family friendly so I think the
the real-time commentary one of the
things that I think makes this show work
is that we've got your comments and
super chats in real time and then we can
answer them doing that in the members
only I think will make it really really
cool so we're gonna we're gonna try that
we're gonna try that out so uh become a
member at timcast.com smash the like
button let's read
I'm not your buddy guy says so this is
how it ends with delusional people
patting themselves in the back for being
virtuous in their signaling wokeness is
the devil
well
you know it's the wedding I can't stand
I guess if it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen I I like that movie The Book of
Eli you guys ever watch that movie
you've never no I've seen that you've
seen it yeah how have you not seen it no
have I not seen it I've never seen
anything you gotta see it okay I'm not
it's basically the world's it's
post-apocalyptic and uh there's a bad
guy and he desperately wants the Bible
and he he basically says that it's a
book that gives you the power to control
people
and it's really great I mean it's not
like the best movie in the world or
anything but the concept is really
interesting it's yeah it's good and I
thought it was a Denzel yeah I don't
want to spoil the movie but the ending
is just it's pretty awesome so you guys
should definitely see it but it's a it's
it's I I dig it I dig it all right let's
see gravity says any chickens scene seem
the monologue yet buck buck seen the
monologue not sure what I don't know but
we really got to do that cast Castle
Yellowstone parody where we're chicken
ranchers and they're trying to come and
take our land
you know baby like Bennett says yo saw
your episode earlier if you're looking
for a new place to set up a shop Western
Kansas is it no nuke targets here and
land is fairly cheap please come to
Kansas yeah you know when we were
looking to set this place up we actually
looked at Montana I would love to live
there but uh and this is well before
watching Yellowstone of course but the
show is correct it is a playground for
rich people and so it's like
Wyoming is probably better
you know but it still has infrastructure
challenges yeah I mean just like Western
Wyoming no cell phones no I was like I
saw Jackson in The Last of Us
that town that they oh yeah yeah that's
Jackson in Wyoming oh really yeah it's
the actual City I think so yeah yeah
Wyoming's cool I went there I have a
story about how we couldn't find gas and
we were driving for like 200 miles we're
like we're gonna run out of gas and then
all of a sudden my friend was like there
look and there was like a Shack on the
side of the road and there was what
looked like weird rectangles where those
are gas pumps oh man we pulled over and
it was like this little dude with his
dog in a shack and he sold it's like a
grocery store and then I was like Wow
there was no signs if we didn't get gas
there we were gonna break down it was
crazy we drove a long time with no and
then the best part was uh when the road
was completely covered in ice and
there's no one around for hundreds of
miles and I'm driving a Honda Civic
Hybrid on just sheets of ice and I'm
like the car's sliding a little bit and
I'm like oh well you know we're gonna
crash and then no one will find us for
for weeks that was totally fun
all right waffle Sensei says Tim says
Raymond and hydro are going to be on his
Friday show bro Raymond and hydro are
going to be co-hosts on my show dog stop
trying to steal my top talent man oh
yeah and Waffles we should get waffles
Raymond and hydro all to come on the new
Friday morning show because yeah think
about all of you guys at the same time
to be insane
Adrian Curry says Montana doesn't want
these people
well according to the show Yellowstone
that is correct they don't want these
people
I I dude he's he John Dunn's Trump yeah
like it's amazing he gets in and he's
and he's like I want to cancel the lease
on the airport and it sounds like you
can't they'll sue you don't care just do
it and then he just does it and they're
like you can't he's like I will I'm
telling you the the I am the wall that
progress like pounds against is the best
speech if you have anything else and you
should find a way to watch that speech
he's like they they want to come here
and turn our land into cities and malls
they call that progress It's like well I
am the wall that progress slams against
yeah it's great I mean and then he's
like we're gonna raise taxes on people
who are have vacation homes here like he
is double the taxes on non-residents of
the people of Montana not the people who
vacation in Montana and I think that
exactly that's a great sentiment yep
maybe like Bennett says I say you start
a charity membership 10 bucks a month
and we vote as a group monthly on who to
donate to and I motion for the first
donation to go to East Palestine since
the feds won't help you know that's a
really good idea
what if we set up a non-profit that did
a like vote-based Foundation thing so
it's like everybody gets to send in
money and then submit where they want
the money for this month to go and then
what we do is we go through every
submission and we just simple script
takes every suggestion and then runs it
like a basic vote so if one person says
I want the money well one vote out of a
hundred thousand ain't getting anything
sorry you lost your vote didn't work but
for some reason
3796 all said East Palestine the
algorithm just pulls it and gives us a
chart of all of the top requests and
then we say hey the number one requested
you know uh charitable donation is to
East Palestine so all of the funds that
went in today will be donated to the
people of the city that'd be a cool idea
yeah um but if there's like a thousand
ten dollar ones and one guy puts ten
thousand in would his vote count as much
as the thousand ten dollars one vote so
then you'd get people splitting their
donations into as many as possible or
getting people to donate for them
um you watch out for for me then then we
do a ten dollar ten dollar limit every
ten dollars is one vote you wanna you
wanna vote 100 you want to vote 10 times
and you put it a hundred dollars okay
um decentralized autonomous
organizations the Dow Dao those are like
can you explain how that would because
you know that's pretty much the same
thing just using smart contracts
as what you're saying but you could do
it manually through a non-profit over
over in the members chat Noah Sanders
says non-profit we'll have that in about
three years just like the fact checking
non-profit timcast yeah really uh you
are correct it exists but the problem is
in order to accept donations you have to
register in each state that would accept
donations there's a bunch of stuff we're
we're dealing with but yo non-profits
are hard to do they're hard to do James
O'Keefe
he did the right thing he wanted to do
right by people so he made a non-profit
and uh you see what happens
they they they boot him out if he
created if if project Veritas was
founded by James as a sole member LLC he
would never have to deal with any of
this but it would be tax deductible true
he'd make more money too
all right let's see
Max Reddick says Tim people like Sam
Cedar will take that clip of you saying
you are tired of nuke threats just do it
already even though you were kidding you
watch it will happen I know it will
there are some conservative commentators
that intentionally produce content they
know the left will make fun of because
it gets them in the algorithm it makes
them famous one of the most beneficial
things to any commentator is if
everyone's talking about you so if you
can get like Hassan for instance to talk
about you 10 times then the left and the
right are talking about you YouTube says
this is something people like show it to
everybody as Jimmy Dore said they've
brought appeal but not the way he
intended it but so you know you just
gotta say something that's easily
baitable like I want Vladimir Putin to
Nuke Ukraine already just be done with
it you know Ukraine should be nuked and
if you said something like that you know
they could take that clip out of context
and then tell everybody that you know
Tim Poole called for uh nuking Ukraine
and it doesn't matter what the context
is like for example if someone were to
say something like we must nuke Ukraine
Russia has to do it Putin is the
greatest president of all time everyone
agrees and anybody was alive anybody
says otherwise is lying and Putin is
obligated to Nuke that country off the
face of the Earth if you said something
like that they would easily be able to
clip that and then accuse you of having
said how would you react or how will you
react when that starts they do when they
do yeah we'll like no but seriously
serious question they do it oh no but
when it becomes like so pervasive it is
yeah it is yo I did a video where I was
like you can't sexually harass women
like if you walk up to a guy who said
this thing the guy's not going to care
you walk up to him and say this thing no
man's going to be like hey don't do that
Young Turks took that and then said Tim
Poole wants to sexually harass women and
they removed the context so I I've had
people be like Do You Hear What Dave
Rubin said and I'm like oh what did Dave
Rubin say oh he said this thing about
that thing and I'm like when did he say
that well I saw it on Twitter and I'm
like dude
you could have someone be like you know
Ian walked in the other day and he went
to me goes I do not like chocolate ice
cream
and then I was like are you kidding me
you really don't and he was like no I'm
just kidding I was like ah you crazy guy
and they'll take that and claim that
quote from a joke story is about you and
you said it that's what they do
it's it's it's so there you go so you
don't you don't care you should think it
should be able to continue to exist and
it's free speech it's free speech yeah
and these people are just evil what do
you do about it right people are it's
it's brutal man it's one of the most
demoralizing things about the internet
is that you like you can see every day
people like Sam Cedar The Young Turks
lying about the opinions of people on
the show because it gets clicks for them
maybe we should build a tool where the
person at hand in the content can at
least
tag it or something to indicate that
it's out of context or something so that
without taking it down without violating
Free Speech there's still some sort of
indication from the people involved who
would have the tag the creator of the
video yeah no no no no no no no no any
but the the person that it's about would
be able to or any maybe anybody could
tag it and that's kind of here's what
you do yeah an extension that sources
the original material so if someone has
a video and they show a clip of me the
extension sees the video clip and then
says original source is this video right
not easy to do but I don't know how you
navigate this stuff man to be honest The
Young Turks basically that's what they
do I I don't know if Jack basically
retired and he's just like tired of
actually being involved in politics but
this is the route they've gone they've
gone the route of just say what the left
wants to hear so they'll click on it we
can go to bed maybe I I hear I you know
I feel that I feel that heat man it'd be
so much more fun to say all the time to
go live in the van down by the river and
then there's probably people like Jan
core like after 20 years of doing this I
mean the guy they had what did Jimmy
Dore said they had upskirting shots on
their website and stuff yeah now they're
just saying whatever they think the left
wants to hear because it gets them just
enough money so that he can he's retired
basically that's how I view it a lot of
these people are like yo I'm ready to
retire can we automate this somehow and
just make the money I'm done wait I mean
what's the point of having a nuanced
take when if you show an upskirt photo
you make just as much money if not more
right I mean there's no motivation in
that you have to be ideologically
motivated posting fake news makes a lot
of money for you and the correction
makes more the correction won't you know
if you if you lie you'll get a thousand
dollars and then the correction makes a
hundred it's all money anyway they don't
give the money back after they correct
the record sir loin tip says to correct
something that was asked last night
calories are absolutely in the food they
are the potential energy found within
the chemical bonds within the carbs fats
and proteins in the food well there you
go
when I was in like seventh or eighth
grade we studied calories by burning
peanuts and you time how long you do the
math to calculate how many joules of
energy star science teachers I'm not
doing a great job but now I think how
could you burn peanuts like that's crazy
that we just burned peanuts because
peanut allergies are so prevalent right
Jimbo says I am disgusted by how
ignorant and complacent we Americans
have become it's 110 our Falls as a
populace for everything our government
is doing not us per se we know better
but low info people it's an enraging
black pill
but as I was saying earlier that way of
life the ignorance can't survive in the
long run because they're not it's not
self-sustainable so after everything
comes crashing down those who do pay
attention do know and do care and have
prepared will take the reins and and
rebuild
all right where are we at what do we got
Timothy Rhodes says Tim what do you
think about the idea of a divorce of
city-states versus actual States kind of
like the Vatican City let SF Chicago New
York Portland Seattle become city-states
no resources sure but not our problem
agreed but why would anyone give up
their slaves if if they've got rural
Farmers paying taxes to their cities why
would they let them go
wandering Mage says if we join the war
there will be a draft and Democrats will
Dodge it and take over while everyone
else is at War a brutal trench war since
drones rendered tanks obsolete I think
draft equal Civil War
that I was reading about the formation
of West Virginia and you want to know
something funny how West Virginia became
a state one of the reasons is that they
held a vote when the young men went to
go fight in the Confederate Army
so you have a region of Virginia they
take all their young men and say go join
and go fight for the Confederates
because you're Virginia it was just it
was just Virginia then once the pro
Confederate side are fighting all that's
left in the city are the anti-war
unwilling to fight don't want Civil War
and they all vote well of course then
they vote to stay in the union isn't it
funny how that works shatters the state
it's not completely why it happened but
that's a component and there was a
lawsuit where after the Civil War ended
Virginia said hey they voted while the
young voting population were half of
them were gone that's not a legitimate
vote in Supreme Court's like yet is Fu
West Virginia exists wow and that's a
good thing because you know West
Virginia's best Virginia and regular
Virginia sucks and it's like woke
garbage
all right
where are we at
hops it up says 20 bucks for a fired up
Ian on train tracks keep up the good
work Tim cast really do appreciate it so
thank you uh so so much for the support
amtrue 13 says James O'Keefe for
president well okay then for president
indeed
Muhammad says I lost a country once I
made America my new home I don't want to
go through it again it's genuinely
painful yeah I feel you man yup yeah
Russell Brand asked me recently I did I
was on the Russell Brand Show and he was
like are you planning on escaping or
whatever and I was like probably not but
if like it really did come down to it El
Salvador all the way like the it you
know shout out to Max and Stacy orange
pill podcast because they they hit the
nail on that they're down there doing a
ton of tremendous work Bitcoin has
basically
created Mass wealth in this country
crime is dropping tourism exploding
tourism exploding um standard of living
skyrocketing and it's because they
banked people instantly overnight all of
a sudden all these poor people had
access to digital transactions and they
were given currency in Bitcoin to
actually spend and the economy just went
and all of a sudden people are trading
with each other it's brilliant stuff I
bet you naive because I bet he would do
the show we used time he's over here
well so that's the challenge he's the
president yeah and he can't just come up
here to you know but we've actually uh
I'll put this way the answer is yes but
the terms are how do we figure out how
do we do it so the interest is there I I
don't want to speak on behalf of the
administer the El Salvadorian
Administration let's just say
intermediate intermediaries we talked to
said they absolutely could get us an
interview with him there's interest
you've got to come to El Salvador and
set up the show and it's going to
bitcoin Beach yeah I know yeah we've
talked about it and we've got people
constantly hitting us up being like just
spend a week in El Salvador do the show
down here and I mean we could but the
challenge is like
our our booking system is real time so
we might get hit up by someone who's
like hey I can come March at this time
and we do and then we have the calendar
is like speckled with guests and it's
like which week do we isolate for El
Salvador we have to plan it way in
advance so maybe uh I don't know June or
something yeah the president one day we
had Max and Stacy one day we could
probably fly Ben Stewart down and we
could fly a few people down there with
us for the week I mean honestly and they
could be on the show it sounds like a
better idea for the new show that I'm
doing where we don't have to worry about
topical news segments conversations like
a lot of people seem to think this show
is for some reason like Joe Rogan and
I'm like it's not like you know people
say like you know why isn't the guests
talk more and I'm like because it's five
people in a room talking about current
news and that's 20 of the conversation
will come from the guest if that so but
the for all pale as hell so we need
that's true Salvador but the the Friday
show was gonna be once a week two hours
long probably and the idea there is
one-on-one hangout conversations
you know that'll that so that means the
Tim the Tim cast news stuff that I do my
monologue con will be Monday through
Thursday
Friday is a terrible news day uh Friday
night's fine because that's where all
the news goes to die so like big stories
drop Friday at 6 p.m so IRL is fine
Friday night you know but a lot of
people are out partying but for the
morning it's like do a cultural
conversation in-depth an individual on a
variety of topics so we've got some cool
stuff we've got some famous musicians
who want to come on a lot of people that
are um you'd be surprised
famous celebrities don't want to do a
news show but would talk about this
stuff in an interview show so we found
that out I don't want to say anybody's
name because I don't want to scare them
off we're booking some big names but
they're basically like oh I couldn't do
IRL because you guys talk about the news
politics politicians I can talk to you
about my experiences with wellness and
stuff but does it fit this format and so
now we got this new show and they're
like oh yeah that sounds great I'll
definitely do that when can we come out
so that's exciting yup we'll see how
that plays out maybe it'll do so well we
just do a lot more of it
hillbillary Clinton says cutter turkey
with my pipeline is what I'm going to do
next Thanksgiving
hopefully my girl will be thankful ha ha
good one uh oh someone's mad ready to
rumble says Ian is an absolute midwit
several years of telling this guy things
Trump has done and he can't remember a
thing complete waste of time talking to
him dude I'm not gonna waste time
drugging up what all he lied about go do
it on your own but you're saying he lied
about things like everybody loves me and
it's like oh okay Trump like that's not
impacting anybody it says him being it's
a lie all right Next Episode Ian will
have a list of top five yeah you want to
do it now take up 20 minutes I mean what
do you guys want to do read super chats
all right where are we at Jimbo says
orange man rad that's right orange man
is red I think Trump was way better in
2016. he was hilarious uh but you know I
think what you got to understand that
they they strapped weights to his ankles
as soon as he got elected like we have
not actually seen a trump presidency
they'll argue that was a good thing they
saved this country yeah right
we got we got as good as we got with
Trump and you guys holding him back
Biden's provably made everything worse
and you're giving him free reign
all right Michael McCord says Trump is a
member of the Mercantile class DeSantis
is a member of the ruling class Trump
wrong schools wrong family made money in
business not a lawyer DeSantis right
schools military service lawyer ruling
class didn't Trump go to UPenn
I don't know you went to University of
Pennsylvania yeah I I know that uh
Ron DeSantis is he's done a lot of good
things I'm not going to be like oh no
he's got bad backers look at all these
good things well he's done good things I
can accept that I'd vote for him I had
to but uh I think it's a no-brainer that
Trump DeSantis is the ticket
I think anybody who's being honest is
gonna it's me like okay but does the
status really want to be a VP
I think that's what he is I don't think
it would be a bad thing for him to be a
VP but I think there are enough people
who don't want Trump to run that and I
don't know to stand to solve it it could
be easy to be talked into like no you
don't want to be VP because then you're
always second fiddle to Trump and this
that and the other like he could I I
don't know but I suspect he could be
talked into seeing it as a negative when
it really wouldn't be I don't I look at
DeSantis
and I think on the scale of presidential
presidentiality with one being the
lowest and 10 being the best
or let's say one being the best
attending the lowest I don't know
whatever Ron DeSantis is a 10. it's like
he's the bottom of presidentiality could
he be president he could but he's not
that presidential Donald Trump is
presidential for weird reasons I don't
know he's a tall boastful loud
commanding guy but
in the VP list Kamala Harris doesn't
even chart at all I don't even know how
she got there Ron DeSantis is number one
he is he's actually slightly above the
best possible choice for a VP in my
opinion because he's almost on on like
presidential level Joe Biden is not
presidential at all he's barely VP how
he got there man is beyond me but that's
why I'm like a trump DeSantis ticket
Kelsey gabbard National Security advisor
and I do think picking DeSantis is an
investment in the future of whatever
movement Trump has created right I mean
if he wins 2024
he can't run again so someone's gonna
have to take his place
Hill bellary Clinton says Hear Me Out
pool Crowder 2024 and their slogan can
be if you crowd the pool we'll kick you
out that will never happen oh that's
funny certainly not
I I couldn't imagine how why someone
would not be in politics you know what I
think I gotta be honest I think most
people get in politics because they're
mediocre people and that's their path
towards the Limelight
hard-working people who want to build
something
they'll do it the hard way and they'll
get to a position of Freedom success
Liberty Etc and then you have people not
every single one don't get me I'm not
trying to insult ever I think there's a
handful of really good politicians who
really do want to do good and they this
is their vehicle but a lot of them are
just like I'm not worth anything my
business isn't that big I'm not famous
I'll run for office yeah you know
uh it's just hard to imagine all of the
restrictions right like think of Matt
Gates being here didn't he say like oh I
I don't know if I can drink that
expensive whiskey like There Are Rules
too he said no I said okay you can't
have any right and like there are all
kinds of rules to like what you can do
how you can spend your money where you
can go your time has to be accounted for
you have to be in your District certain
amount of time like I think that there
are a lot of people who are great and
have a lot of positive effect who don't
necessarily want to give up the things
that people who become the president
have to give up
all right Big Joe says I want to see a
congressional congregational cage match
it would accomplish just as much as they
do now at least it'd be entertaining
yeah
yeah rondelle Schmidt says Tim I think
you should do some kind of fundraiser
for all the people affected from the
train derailment I think you could
really raise a lot to help
um what we would need to do is find a
charity or non-profit that does that and
then we could do a show where we're like
let's see how much money we can raise
for them we don't have the legal
capacity to to accept money for anybody
like that so we couldn't do it
um I also want to just as an aside
mention there are now bocus emojis and
Golden
Rooster emojis
available to members in the chat on
YouTube so if you want people post I see
people posting little bocus faces
Focus faces maybe we need to make a
bogus wearing a beanie that'd be good
see Albright says I'm a shift manager at
a burger joint from Cali I am looking to
move if you're still looking for help at
your coffee shop I'd love to apply it is
under construction I guess like the the
contractors have come in they've mapped
everything up they're planning
everything out then we're going to have
a second floor skate shop hangout games
and stuff and then like private club
third floor or something like that I
don't know it's coming along
oh everybody's spamming golden you know
roosters and bocus emojis now
Focus emojis
yeah because it's a cat
all right where are we at
Alan uh schroer if this is coo then the
proper role for him is Chief of Staff VP
is neutered no more Scott for VP Tulsi
has secretary of defense agreed
yeah there we go agreed it's just
unusual of a chief of staff then
transition to you know running for
president I don't know of anyone who's
you know successfully launched that kind
of campaign and he's already Governor so
that doesn't seem I I VP may be neutered
in some capacity but they could do it
right and it would give him a chance
like people say one of the weakest
things for Santa's his uh foreign policy
experience like in the VP you would
probably have more
chance to interact with Federal foreign
policy I don't know it's just a thought
yeah
all right where were we
Jake says Trump went to New York
Military Academy where he did very well
I'm sure he's walked more than most with
the CEO screaming and marching right
behind him too Fair Point and that's why
I said I don't want to single out Trump
because you know on the golf course
obviously he's walking too outside of
military school but there are people who
are born to wealthy families who
probably have not walked a mile not
crazy to think they go out of their
house and probably the only time they
walk a mile is when they're on the golf
course
they just car waiting for me driving for
a Leisure and not for purp like for
function I don't want to be hyperbolic
about Trump either I did find one of his
lies and they seem to like come out of
the woodwork ah that he likes Wikileaks
I think in 2016 he said quote Wikileaks
I love Wikileaks and then in 2019 I know
nothing about Wikileaks so how does that
contradict so he says he knew nothing
about it but that was a lie because he
used to love them now he pretends like
he doesn't know anything about it why he
lets his attorney general just spearhead
Assange and take him into prison so see
this this is what the media did all the
time I can certainly understand where
you're like I see what Trump is doing
I'm not going to give the benefit out on
this one but it's like someone going
like I absolutely love Lindor truffles
delicious chocolate and then someone
says what's in it and you go I don't
know anything about it and then they go
how you lied yeah but three it's like
saying I love
The Infinity Gauntlet it's my favorite
comic book three years later he said I
love it what about the infinity I don't
know anything about The Infinity
Gauntlet see this is what the media does
Trump said I love Wikileaks he loved
them when they were when they were
exposing Hillary Clinton's emails and
then when asked more specific questions
about what he was doing I don't know
yeah well three years later when he was
asked about it when he was so so that's
what the media does did Trump lie in
that regard what you're saying is quite
literally not a lie he obviously knew
about Wikileaks when he said I I know
nothing about Wikileaks he knew about
him he knew
16 he was praising Assange and Wikileaks
this is this is what the media does you
are you are taking something Trump said
that was vague and nondescript applying
your personal worldview to his to his
statement and then being upset are you
you're saying it's another instance of
hyperbole is that what you're saying
what I'm saying is I can go I love
Infinity Gauntlet and then you go what
did Thanos say to to death and I'm like
I don't know no it'd be like you're
saying I love it then like a couple days
later I go oh yeah Tim loves Infinity
gallon you like I don't know anything
about Infinity Gauntlet I'd be like what
you just said you loved it and I do but
I want to say you don't know anything
about it because it's true how can you
love something you don't know anything
about see that's what you don't
understand you are ascribing your world
view to a statement I said because you
didn't ask me the context Donald Trump
could be saying I love Wikileaks because
someone said you say they really
something about Hillary Clinton oh I
love it it's fantastic then later
someone says but Julian Assange did
these things with Afghanistan and the
war logs and Trump goes well I don't
know anything about it okay if your
stance is that he didn't lie about not
knowing about within okay you don't
think this is what the media does Trump
trump they will assign context to his
statements you can say Trump was trying
to backpedal because I I'm like sure I
get it if that's how you view it but if
Trump comes out and says I love
Wikileaks and then someone says oh you
do who's at second in command is I don't
know I don't think about it
that's not a lie well what was the
context of him saying I don't know
anything about it was it trying like
that matters because if he's trying to
get out of having ever said that he
supported it in a way so that he can
because what was manipulative was that
he made everyone think that he was going
to potentially pardon Assange but then I
don't think so yeah he was like 30 let's
find thirty thousand more of her emails
the ones that disappeared that's recent
2016 2018 2019 the context is he said I
know nothing after Assange was arrested
he said I know nothing about Wiggly it's
not my thing and I know there's
something having to do with Julia sanj
I've been seeing what's happening with
Assange and that will be a determination
I would imagine mostly by the Attorney
General is doing an excellent job like
what he just sold the guy out so
objectivity is Donald Trump says he
loves Wikileaks okay he did not say I
know everything about Wikileaks I know
all about Julian Assange I'm gonna
pardon the man because I love him so
much and then later they said hey you're
still gonna do that I don't know
anything about it don't look at me
that's not what happened someone said
wow a bunch of emails got released you
see on Tucker Carlson and then he goes I
love this I love the Wikileaks what you
know these documents getting released
then later on they go Julian Assange is
accused of rape and he goes well I don't
know anything about yeah they're
separate statements but it's similar to
kind of the criticism that he said he
was going to drain the swamp and then
what actually got trained I mean he
could have Trump has the ability to
declassify as much material as he wanted
he could have you saw how they could
have gone on an absolutely Rampage
exposing everything you saw how that
went the FBI raids his house
and the federal government still comes
after him look
Trump lies about stupid things no
question about it but I I what I can't
stand is
if Trump gives me a vague nondescript
statement I will not apply context to it
that does that does not exist so that is
not a good example of trump lying I mean
set it on the campaign trail that he
loves Wikileaks and then after Assange
had arrested he said he doesn't know
anything about Wikileaks yeah how is
that not a lot it's a weird linguistic
kind of content is it's a weird
linguistic trick no it isn't lying would
be him saying I know everything about
Julian Assange and I love the man then
someone goes a year later so do you
still love Julian Assange I don't know
who that is yes that would also be a lie
but Trump didn't do that well it was a
different a lie I mean it's like no
that's he didn't say elephants are
yellow and purple when Trump said last
night in Sweden you see what happened
and the media said Trump's insane
nothing happened in Sweden because what
Trump meant was last night on Tucker
Carlson they talked about Sweden did you
see what happened the media assigned
fake context to what he was saying to
accuse him of lying they do it all the
time then maybe it's annoying because
I'm trying to understand the truth what
are Trump's motivations what is he
really getting at and the reality is
this Wikileaks releases emails Trump
doesn't know anything about it someone
asks him and he goes oh I love the
Wikileaks I love this here's what the
he's talking about then he's a liar
no he's not well he's laying in the news
and he said I love this yeah but he
didn't but because he didn't know what
it was is what you're saying see that's
Trump derangement syndrome no I'm not
the range I know a liar when I see one
dude you got TDS bad I I mean if you if
you want to slob the knob bro go I don't
know what to do that's that's another
good example of it what are you saying
you're saying what his lie is not a lie
I don't know what to say what did he
they're they're they're better examples
I'm sure the fact that you can't explain
why Trump said he loved Wikileaks he
loved Wikileaks because it was exposing
Hillary and he loved it he loved the
idea he was talking about on the
campaign even encouraged the Russians to
fight quote find the 30 000 emails from
Clinton's server has nothing to do with
Wiki that's why he loved it it's because
it was exposing those emails so so let
me explain to to those that are still
listening I'm trying to understand the
truth you are obfuscating it you are
making it difficult to understand this
is one instance of many where maybe he
was just lie maybe he's just saying
think something he didn't mean when he
said he loved something that he didn't
maybe he didn't know anything about you
can love something you don't know much
about I that is not true that is not
love see you're intentionally making
things confusing I don't know a whole
lot about football at all I love the
Super Bowl we had a Super Bowl party it
was so much fun I tell people I love
Super Bowl parties then later people go
oh yeah you're a big fan of the chief so
I only think about him he said you love
the Super Bowl dude were you lying no I
love the Super Bowl friends come over
the game's on I don't really know what's
going on but I love you love the
Gatherings but the game itself is not in
your right you don't love it but I say I
love it Super Bowl you'd be considered a
fair weather fan if you said that to a
real football you see how you're trying
to make it confusing to understand
reality here we had a Super Bowl party I
love Super Bowl parties that's different
than loving the soup we got we got a
gallon and a half of crab dip
great we played poker the game was on
people were cheering they did squares
and all that stuff and I know nothing
about football so if someone came and
asked me oh you're having a Super Bowl
party you love the Super Bowl I love it
it's so much fun the game's on people
are cheering I know a little bit about
it and then a year later they're like
you love football right and I'll be like
I don't know anything really about it
you came out and you said you love
football well I was talking about the
Super Bowl we did this one thing this
one time Donald Trump sees a story about
emails getting released and he goes I
love this this Wikileaks thing later on
someone asked him a specific question
about something related because I know
anything about it wouldn't be like you
saying you love the Super Bowl
you'll be saying you love this Super
Bowl and then I go oh yeah you love the
Super League no I don't know anything
about that the statements can co-exist
but it's it's a it's a how can you love
something you know nothing about Bill
what's in chocolate what's in what's it
do you like chocolate again yeah what
are the ingredients of of like a Lindor
truffle
could you love it if you don't know what
you're eating you asked me if I like
chocolate it's cacao what's a Lindor
truffle it's not it's
in a Lindor truffle maybe you can like
something without knowing what goes ask
me if I like the Lindor truffle maybe
different statements I think Trump's
saying I don't know about Wikileaks in
the second sentence is just as easily
interpreted as I don't want to comment
on that that's what it was I don't want
to talk about it but that's okay right
if you were the president of the United
States and you're walking by I don't
know what the context was let's say he's
going to bore Air Force One someone
calls out hey do you know what's going
on it's Julian Assange he's like I don't
know but you know the Attorney General's
on it things are good I don't think that
negates the fact that he was happy with
the work they were doing at a different
in a different context right he's not
saying I've never heard of Julian
Assange and I hate everything about
Wikileaks like he's not reversing well
he might as well have reversed because
he didn't do anything okay it's
different though
you love James oh hold on you love James
O'Keefe yeah I like him so you you like
what he did to uh that employee Janet I
don't know Janet
what are you talking about you lied then
three years if you asked me if I said
that I like James O'Keefe I wouldn't
tell you I don't know anything about him
but if I said hey do you like what's
going on with project Veritas you might
say I don't know what's going on with
projects I don't know anything about it
I don't know anything about it right
like James or what I mean but that's
what I mean like so you're like I say I
like project Veritas and then three
years later you asked me about it and I
said I don't know anything about project
Veritas that would be a lie because I I
already I'm on camera telling you I like
it
but you're saying that you if okay hold
on hold on
everybody in the chat
and I think the three of us all agree
Ian I think you have trumped
Arrangements I don't think he has Trump
Rangers I I think that this is an
understandable argument I disagree I
I've been consistently in the position
of trump does bad things and Trump lies
but I'm sick of the media lying about
what he says or does in an attempt to
make people hate him
and so
I just feel like Ian you've you've found
one weird example you're trying to
justify that Trump is a liar because you
didn't find anything the first one that
came up on CNN sure it's not really a
lie it's a bad example so he could have
said I don't want to talk about it and
that would have been him owning it
instead he acted like he can't even talk
about it because he doesn't know
anything about it that's it Trump
derangement syndrome means that there is
no way no Universe in which you would
ever change your mind and I know for a
fact that Ian there is a world in which
he would I would not exactly
Trump derangement syndrome is this is
the perfect example of it there's
there's a viral comedic video that came
out during the Trump Administration
where a guy said stop making me defend
Trump and it's this video where it's
like they're playing someone's watching
TV and they're like can you believe that
Trump called all Mexicans rapist animals
and the guy goes he looks and he goes
he turns around he sees him because
Trump never said that and they go why
are you defending Trump are you Trump
supporter and he goes no but Trump never
said that and they're like you're a
you're a white supremacist you support
Trump and he's like what are you talking
that never happened Joe Biden launched
his campaign on claiming Trump praised
white nationalists it literally never
happened
Trump speaks in vague terms often
because he doesn't know what he's
talking about he hears a crowd cheering
for something and he says I love it I
love it and he's being vague in speaking
in general terms then you can ask him
something very specific later on about I
know what you're talking about and maybe
he also just doesn't remember but but 16
seconds Wikileaks I love Wikileaks in
2016. and what does that mean for him it
could mean whatever could mean he
doesn't even know what they are but he
says he loves it it's like someone
bringing you a Papa John's Pizza you eat
it and everyone starts saying oh did you
like that pizza you're like I love Papa
John's it's so good and then three years
later someone's like did you hear about
Papa John's and what happened with the
racist thing you go I don't think about
Papa John's and you're not he lied like
dude they're totally different contexts
someone should let's let's Super Chat
the best the top lie undeniable let's
try and do let's try and do the members
only live so go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna try and do the
members only show live we'll see if it
works should be fun I guess I don't know
if it'll work we'll see if we can make
it happen so go to tipguys.com click the
join us button smash the like button
subscribe to the channel subscribe to
this YouTube channel share the show with
your friends you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me at timcast
Bill do you want to shout anything out
yeah everyone so April 14th timcast IRL
live in Austin April 15th mindsfest at
the Vulcan same venue so everyone who's
in town for Tim cast IRL please come out
I'm just going to read the lineup quick
it's it's it's badass we got
Destiny Brian Collin Peter bagosian
Daryl Davis Chris Williamson
Carrie Smith Jamie killstein doing some
stand up
um Matthew Israeli
Michael Seifert from Public Square
Ian Crossland Luke radowski we've got
cows really yes okay he just pronounces
it wrong on purpose oh does he uh yeah
Brian Callan Layton Woodhouse who's a
Twitter files journalist Jack pesobic
and then we got live music presented by
base records Ira Dean Jeffrey Steele and
Suzanne Santo so it's going to be live
podcast debates comedy it's going to be
an absolute blast please come out it's
going to be rock where do people get
tickets tickets Dot vulcanpresents.com
that's awesome cool yes uh I'm here
Claire brimwell I'm a writer for
timcast.com if you want to follow me
personally you can follow me on
Instagram at hannahclar.b you can follow
me on Twitter at HC brimo and you should
110 definitely follow first Tim cast
news at timcast news on Twitter and
Instagram and you should also check out
pop culture crisis I did a show with
them today Ian's on the show pretty
regularly it's a great time and they're
pretty cool
all right bye everybody bye Ian
Crossland remember you can be deranged
out of obsessive love you could be
deranged out of obsessive hate do not be
deranged call things as you see them I
love you and take care of yourself
and I am search.com as always uh this
live show will work let's get to it all
right so we should have that members
only live show up in a couple minutes
usually when we wrap everyone wants to
like run to the bathroom and get a drink
of water so yes it'll be up at uh on the
front page of timcast.com in maybe like
five or so minutes and we'll see you
there